MonkaS, Mon, Mon, MonkaS.
MonkaW.
Ja!
So.
So, wieder am Start.
Kein VMWare?
Nee, warum soll ich denn VMWare
auf einem NAS installieren?
ok das ist gut das ist gut zu wissen
und man kann die auch auf und zu machen
und da richtig positionieren da hat er
weil ein problem damit also wenn das
geht dann wird zwar zeit für das
Meme Overlay Board
zu
wie nennt man das? Remastern.
Für Linux.
Kann denn, da müssen wir gerade mal nachgucken, wo wir dabei sind.
Kann man?
Avalonia
GIFs
Kann das GIFs anzeigen?
GIF-Renderer und Player für Avalonia
Ach
Archived ist es
Archived
Archivet
Achso Moment
Es gibt eine offizielle GIF-Funktion
Okay da habe ich nichts gesagt
Egal ob das
Archived ist oder nicht
die leute streiten sich bis heutzutage ob es ein gift ist oder ein gif und wir wissen ja
auch dass jason sauer ist wie kommst du zu boxen auf der aspelle aber als nach so es
taugt es mir nicht so sehr doch da dem ja weil ich das nass für virtualisierung container und
ab und zu mal Netzwerk-Share verwende.
Das ist halt ein NAS.
Aber ein NAS mit einem 8-Kern-CPU,
32 GB RAM und 3 NVMe-SSDs
drin.
Also das ist schon recht
stark
CPU-mäßig.
Und eine Radeon 780M.
Das ist schon recht stark für nur
Netzwerk-Freigaben.
ja aber ich war schon kein großer fan von wpf ich glaube ich habe das damals nur mit wpf gemacht
weil damit transparenz ganz gut ging das war ja mal paint shampoo der windows forms und es
eine ordentliche skif control gab auf github was aber sagt weil es so viel ram braucht also ich
Wir können auch immer noch mit FFmpeg das GIF rendern.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber das ist ein sehr schönes Projekt.
Das werde ich mal aufschreiben.
Das Memeboard muss unter Linux Wayland laufen.
OBS und so tut ja ohne Probleme.
doch er kommt post werde ich auch benutzen ich mache mir dann doch blau
drauf habe ich mir überlegt wo mein ganzes zeug und wird einfach alles was
locker ist in der vm mit doch blau laufen lassen
das einzige was ich wahrscheinlich in einem container auf box laufen lasse ist
der den sammler mit oder vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht das probieren wir
heute mal vielleicht installiere ich auch in open media world in der vm und guck mal wie da die
performance ist weil samba config ist so endgegner für mich ich checke nie ich vergesse immer was
entweder vergesse ich das user passwort oder ich vergesse die share berechtigung oder ich
checke nicht also samba config ist painz champ ein paar möglichkeiten müssen wir mal ausprobieren
Aber als erstes müssen wir mal die Onboard-Netzwerkkarte, ich mach mal die VM an.
Als erstes müssen wir mal gucken, wie gut die Onboard-Netzwerkkarte ist.
Und damit wir mal einen Vergleich haben, werden wir jetzt mal kurz iPerf für Windows runterladen.
iPerf.
Windows?
Gab es da nicht irgendwelche Windows-Builds?
ipad für windows oder oder noch besser ich sie soll noch ipad suche nicht per
ipad windows bild ja das hier das hier okay aber mal was anderes
lasst uns mal was gucken hier wie geht das wenn jetzt search ipad habe ich
doch gemacht was was ist da jetzt ach so wenn man es richtig schreibt dann
funzt vielleicht auch ja ja wir stimmen zu ipf das ist hier der asia der egen
da kann man uns aber auch einfach von github runterladen den hatten wir doch
eben auch hier irgendwo da ipad 3 binaries für windows releases haben eine windows zip windows
64 an den vier wien 64 brauchen wir dann let's go moment es ist die linux anwendung
das ist die linux anwendung einfach für windows schaufel ich gemacht okay das ist kein native
das ist kein native windows bild es ist mir aber ehrlich gesagt egal ob es nicht die für
ein ausbildes will ist ja nur kurz ausprobieren so zack ok wenn wir das mal kurz rum ipf ich will
Warum Windows?
Warum?
Warum hast du das dahin sortiert, wenn ich nur den Namen ändere?
Wird das immer umsortiert,
wenn man den Namen ändert?
Nee, nicht immer.
Nicht immer.
Leute, wo ist das?
Wo ist das Microslop-E-Mode?
Ich hab's extra hinzugefügt.
Da.
Sekunde, Leute.
Ich brauche das hier.
Ich muss das kurz runterladen.
Was zum Teufel ist Afif für ein Format?
WebM kenne ich.
Was zum Teufel ist Afif?
Image.
was ist das vor allem das gibt er
das brauchen wir das brauchen wir in nächster zeit noch öfters glaube ich
ich glaube das ist bald an der tagesordnung also täglich okay also probier was mal aus
terminal cd ja nervt nicht um desktops install the latest powershell wie warum habe ich nicht
die latest powershell ich mache doch immer windows update das wenn auskommen es macht
Wir sind mittlerweile an einem Punkt angelangt, wo es einfach schon gar keinen Sinn mehr macht, diesen ganzen Mist zu hinterfragen.
So, IPerf3-C212.148.
Okay, also.
Wir kriegen von meiner Windows-Kiste auf meinen aktuellen Unraid-Server 9,5 Gibbs.
und umgedreht
9,1. Okay.
Ja, das ist okay. Also
9,5, also sag mal 9
bis 9,5
Gigabits pro Sekunde
kriegen wir hin. Auf meinen aktuellen
Android-Server von meiner Windows-Kiste.
Das müssen wir jetzt halt mit dem NAS ausprobieren,
wie das da sich verhält.
Soll ich euch mal,
weil gestern ein paar gefragt haben,
wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe,
wollen wir mal zusammen ins BIOS von der
nasskiste gucken weil ich glaube mich haben gestern leute gefragt kann man
rammus von der grafikkarte einstellen unsere zeugte wir können uns das kann
mal zusammen angucken hier mein spiel
chat seid ihr auch so wie ich und sagt videos anstatt efi ich werde für immer
bios sagen
Nö, Knopf.
Yep, yep, Clock.
Okay.
Also, hier sind wir.
Ich werde nie,
ich werde nie irgendwie
anfangen mit...
Ich weiß,
ich weiß gar nicht, wo steht denn eigentlich
EFI und EFI? Unified?
Interface?
Also das I ist Interface?
Firmware Interface?
Unified?
Was auch immer?
Firmware Interface?
Stimmt, ins BIOS sagen die.
Extensible, okay.
Ins BIOS sagen die coole Leute.
Ja gut, hast recht.
Guck mal, das ist das BBS-Menü.
Was auch immer das BBS-Menü ist.
Chat, Chat.
Ich hab grad für einen ganz kurzen Moment gedacht,
weil hier unten dritter Eintrag ist,
meine
Mellanox-Karte
würde auf einmal zu Bouten zur Auswahl stehen.
Aber dann ist mir eingefallen, kann nicht sein.
Und zweitens, ich habe die ausgebaut.
Hier ist nicht drin.
Okay.
Also, Setup.
Was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Ich war da schon drin und habe eingestellt.
Also, ich bin jetzt nicht blind hier drin.
So, hier kann man Gedöns einstellen.
Juckt jetzt nicht wirklich.
Die Uhrzeit stimmt.
Juckt mich persönlich aber auch überhaupt nicht.
So.
Manufaktor ist
Maigao Innovation aus
Shenzhen
China-Chinesen
Was sonst?
Minis Forum
N5R AI-NAS
Warum das Ding
AI in dem Produkttitel
drinstehen hat, ich hab keine Ahnung
Macht aus meiner Sicht auch
überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass da
AI dran steht, das einzige wie ich mir
das erklären kann ist, dass AI
dass das Management denkt
AI macht sich einfach gut.
Das ist das Einzige.
Das Ding hat absolut nichts mit AI zu tun.
Wir werden aber nachher
mal Olamar drauflaufen lassen
oder wie heißt das?
Kobalt CPP drauflaufen lassen.
Ja, mache ich.
Ich lasse es ja auch drauflaufen nachher.
Mal gucken, wie schnell das ist.
Ist das ein AI-Prozessor?
Das ist ein Ryzen
Ryzen 7 255.
Keine Ahnung, ob das ein AI-Prozessor ist.
Wartungsfenster?
Die Referenz checke ich nicht.
Mit dem Passwort.
Und wer zum Teufel ist LKW Peter?
Ich kenne Klaus, den Staplerfahrer.
Oder wie war das?
Das war aber auch schon vor meiner Zeit.
Das fand nur auf meiner alten Arbeit einer furchtbar lustig.
Und musste mir das unbedingt mal zeigen.
Ich fand das eher ein bisschen cringe.
Masterpasswort fürs BIOS
Dein Masterpasswort fürs BIOS ist LKW Peter
Ich google jetzt nicht LKW Peter
Wer weiß, wo man da rauskommt am Ende
Oder kann man das?
Kann man das googeln?
Okay, ich trau euch mal
LKW Peter
Wann hat der Chat mir schon mal Backdoor?
Ach, das war ein Default-Passwort für ein BIOS mal eine Weile, oder wie?
LKW Peter!
Hahaha!
Das kann ich nicht!
Das hab ich noch nie gehört!
LKW Peter!
Hahaha!
Das ist ja geil!
Ami, wir sind bei LKW Peter!
LKW Peter.
Ist das Zufall?
Ist das Zufall, dass es LKW Peter
auf Deutsch heißt?
Oder wollte das wirklich
einer absichtlich so machen?
LKW Peter.
Das ist mal was. Das wusste ich nicht.
Das ist mir komplett neu.
Ich weiß nur,
dass Java
Programmer haben als
Identifikationsheader
Kaffee Babe
Kaffee Babe.
Ich Kaffee Bebe.
Kaffee Babe
haben die Java Leute.
Also Java Programme
starten immer hier mit diesem
Byte, mit diesen Bytes.
Okay, also gucken wir uns mal das BIOS an.
Oh, sorry.
Das BIOS.
Wir gehören ja zu den coolen Leuten.
Wir sagen auch Amazon.
Oder Amazon.
Ich habe schon Leute auf YouTube.
Leute, es ist Amazon oder Amazon.
Weil ich habe auch schon in Werbung teilweise,
oder nicht Werbung, ich weiß nicht, in YouTube-Videos,
Leute Amazon sagen hören.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder die Frage,
British oder American English oder so.
Amazon
Nee Amazon nicht
Product Name
N5A was ist daran sass
Achso
NSA.
Stimmt.
Da wäre ich ja gar nicht dran.
NSA. Ja, stimmt.
SAS-Produktname.
Weiß man gar nicht.
Ob das A jetzt für R oder für AI steht,
könnte beides sein.
Aber vielleicht steht das Ganze auch für NSA.
Chat.
Die sind bestimmt schon drinnen.
Aber macht das Sinn,
dass das China-Chinesen-Hardware-NSA
und die NSA was zusammen?
Nee.
Wie heißt die NSA von den China-Chinesen?
Die haben doch bestimmt auch sowas.
Das Geheimdienstministerium
oder so.
Also, Top-Seriennummer,
UID, alles ganz toll.
Juckt mich nicht. Okay, also BIOS.
Gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Advanced, Trusted Computing, das machen wir gleich mal wieder zu, wen juckt's?
SHA-384-PCR-Bank ist disabled.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir manchmal wünschen würde, schon seit Jahrzehnten, was BIOS und EFI-Sachen angeht?
Wenn es im BIOS, anstatt diese nichtssagenden Untertitel oder Sachen, die früher standen hier rechts auf der Seite vom BIOS,
irgendwie mal eine 212
Sätze Erklärung gibt,
was das eigentlich ist.
Weil, was zum Teufel ist
Scha384PCRBank?
Guck mal jetzt mal.
Scha384PCRBank.
Was ist das?
Sammlung von Plattformen
Konfigurationsregistern
in einem TPM Sicherheitsmodus.
Okay, leck mich TPM.
Geh fort, weg, next.
Nein, nein, nein, bloß nicht
Okay, next, CPU Configuration
Wir können PSS Support
Und NX Mode aktivieren
Wir lassen das mal auf Default
Oder
Was, Enable, Disable, keine Ahnung, brauchen wir nicht
Ich weiß nicht, was ist das
Ah, Moment, ich kann nicht Escape drücken
Das ist natürlich
Unpraktisch jetzt hier drinnen
Aber kann ich, Moment, kann ich hier Escape drücken
Ah, wenn ich so, dann müssen wir es so lassen
Okay, CPU-Configuration hatten wir.
Onboard-Device-Settings.
NVMe-Rate-Mode.
Disabled. Ja, ich will auch ZFS machen.
Da wird hier nichts enabled.
Was gibt es denn zur Auswahl? Nur mal so, theoretisch.
Okay.
Ich mach da gar nichts dran.
also wir haben
APC-Port kann man hier noch Zeug einstellen
den Oculink-Port
hab ich deaktiviert, der ist nicht standardmäßig
deaktiviert, hier kann man irgendwelche
Power-Save-Sachen noch aktivieren und deaktivieren
aber ganz ehrlich, ich lass das einfach
auf
Auto stehen alles
5G-Klan hab ich deaktiviert
bisschen Strom sparen können wir machen
weil, wird nicht viel brauchen
aber ich brauch den 5G-Port nicht
ja, es ist auch cool
Das Ding ist eh mega geile Hardware.
Man darf, guck mal, 5 Bays, 3 interne NVMe SSDs,
einen internen USB-Anschluss für beispielsweise Unraid,
ein Oculink-Port, ordentlich viele USB-Sachen,
ein PCI-Express-Slot, 16-fach PCI-Express-Slot.
Also das Ding ist wirklich rund um POC von der Hardware.
Mal gucken, wie gut das unter Linux dann letztendlich auch alles funktioniert.
Eine gute 8-Kern-CPU und eine Radeon 280M.
Also man kann auch ein bisschen lokale LLMs oder so laufen lassen.
Aber nichts Großartiges, muss man gleich dazu sagen.
Ja.
Das DXP6800 braucht aber deutlich mehr RAM.
Das Ding hier braucht, ich hab's mal angeschlossen, ich hab nix im BIOS eingestellt.
Ich hab nur mal eingeschaltet, als es neu war, mit der 64-Gig-internen SSD.
da das 11,5 watt gebraucht dass der die ukraine dinge brauchen deutlich mehr so
gucken wir mal weiter hier okulink ist disabled okay der rest der rest ist
eigentlich nur was auch immer ssd-dings ist wir schlossen das alles auf auto
stehen so dann kann man hier noch einstellen die led kann man ein aus
machen ganz ehrlich soweit werde ich nicht gehen zum strom sparen um die led
auszumachen das braucht ja nichts so dann haben wir da war man gerade acp settings
weg und lahn ist enabled ganz ehrlich das könnte man theoretisch auch ausmachen weil
werde ich wahrscheinlich ähnlich verwenden im 19 zoll gehäuse
Ja, wobei ich ehrlich gesagt glaube, die wenden sich so an Heimanwender, die nicht unbedingt vielleicht einen Rack da haben.
Aber es wäre natürlich cool, wenn es alternativ das gleiche System einmal in normaler Bauweise und einmal in 19 Zoll Bauweise gäbe.
Das wäre tatsächlich cool, ja.
Also Hardware-Monitor.
heute Morgen hat jemand gefragt,
ich glaube der Abriss-Johnny war das, wie das mit der
Lüfter-Lautstärke aussieht. Aktuell ist
es relativ
ja, also es ist, aktuell
ist es zu laut für,
würde ich sagen, fürs Wohnzimmer, wenn man leise
Sachen guckt. Aber man kann das hier alles
einstellen, man kann
die Drehzahl
vom, guck mal, 250%
KQ, vom
SSD-Lüfter, vom Festplatten-Lüfter und
für die, der hier ist übrigens
standardmäßig nicht benutzt.
Und man kann
hier die Kurve einstellen,
ab wann der Vivo hochdrehen soll.
Also, man kriegt das, ich hab's gestern
mal kurz ausprobiert, man kriegt das tatsächlich
auf nahezu lautlos.
Wenn man da jetzt halt volle
Pulle Last drauf macht, alle Kerne auslastet,
dann wird's nie lautloser, ist ja logisch.
AMD PBO
auf eco stellen mal gucken ich weiß gar nicht was das ist so dann haben wir hier networkstech
configuration den habe ich schon mal eingeschaltet damit er überhaupt pxe booten kann wieder witzig
aus hier mit den zwei mauszeigern will man die will man es fünf nicht in ebel kann man durchaus
erneben brauche ich aber nicht wenn man es hier weiß gar nicht wo stand das jetzt hier ich benutze
keinen kein halber nation das ding läuft 24 7 denn ich dass das probleme macht wobei doch das
macht probleme eventuell ich habe nämlich gelesen dass unser linux probleme gibt mit der onboard 10
gegner zwei karte dass die manchmal nach standby nicht mehr erkannt wird und man wirklich hat
mit machen muss px er hat funktioniert pxe mit der onboard karte werden wir jetzt machen mit
meiner zusätzlichen netzwerkkarte habe ich nicht zum laufen gekriegt aber ganz ehrlich das ding
ist schrott ich habe es mittlerweile ausgebaut so network stack configuration haben wir gerade
schon jetzt kommt amd cbs fragt mich nicht wofür cbs steht da können wir jetzt ein revision number
00, klingt auch gut.
CPU Options.
Performance Boost.
Global C-State Control.
Das lasse ich alles.
Das lasse ich alles auf Auto.
Man kann hier eventuell die ein oder
anderen Stromverbrauchssachen noch
tunen, wenn man weiß, was die einzelnen
Dinger bedeuten.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. C-States sind
ja diese Energiesparmodi
von der CPU.
Aber was der Unterschied hier ist zwischen
Auto und enable, keine Ahnung.
Da lasse ich auch mal die Finger von.
SVM
lock, SVM enabled, keine Ahnung
was es ist.
SVM
war Virtualisierung.
Ne, oder?
SVM
lock.
Virtualisierungsfunktion.
Alter, die AI labert für der Müll,
Alter. Die Virtualisierungsfunktion
wie Docker, ja alles ist klar, nice.
computer base einschalten wenn du vor dem laufen lassen willst otd oder vd das ist es vor mb amd
okay das ist in der bild macht ja auch sinn wir wollen wir virtualisieren gab es hier noch mehr
so was haben wir was haben als nächstes in bio das hier wird aktiviert als er doch mal irgendwelche
sachen durchreichen wollen an die vm und sowas würde ich das thema immer aktivieren dm support
no help string die anderen helft sind auch nicht sonderlich hilfreich ich lasse das alles mal auf
auto stehen audio configuration die habe ich tatsächlich disabled ich werde damit keine
audio machen und bisschen strom sparen schadet ja nix gfx configuration habe ich gestern umgestellt
auf auto ursprünglich steht das ganze auf uma specified war um nicht dieses eine fisch aus
richard 3 also ja doch doch ich kann mich auch daran aber ich weiß in dem fall nicht wofür es
steht man kann ja nämlich nicht kleiner als ein gig gehen also es wird immer ein gig vom
arbeitsspeicher abgeknapst für die gpu und wenn man es hier auf uma auto stellt ist es witzigerweise
nur 512 mb was abgezweigt wird oder warum auch immer ich lasse jetzt mal auf uma auto stehen
mehr kann man hier nicht machen fch 8 power power loss options gut always of das ist durchaus okay
dass er sich nicht automatisch einschaltet nach einem stromausfall ich
meine ich werde es dann eher eine usv dran haben aber das darf ruhig am
stromausfall ausbleiben weil er kann sich nicht hochfahren also kann ich
hochfahren aber ich muss ja dann die dass die festplatte die krypten und
deswegen macht ja keinen sinn so smu configuration options da kann man
irgendwie temperatur limit einstellen lasse ich auch mal die finger von smart
keine ahnung was es wissen die hersteller selbst nicht auch keine ahnung was es macht sie will
dass ich auch die finger von das hat man gerade und dann gibt es auch ddr configuration und das
ist das was ich gestern gefunden habe man kann hier etc erneben die cpu kann aber kein etc was
nur sv viele leute haben usv eine ganz kleine apc usv was geht wir kommen uns gerade bios von
der nasskiste an ich habe eine ganz kleine billige apc usw ich hatte meine cyber power usv davor die
war aber richtig schrott da ging nämlich die geräte nicht mehr als die batterie davon mal
kaputt ging und meine apc usv ist auch so wie sich das für eine billige usv gehört wie nennt
man das offline usw wer hat wer hat in seiner abschlussprüfung aufgepasst ich
glaube offline usw nennt sich das wenn er standardmäßig an der batterie
vorbeigeht und erst wenn das job quasi die batterie eingeschaltet wird
so und das war's ich glaube jetzt haben wir alle bios options an die moment
moment da haben wir uns noch gar nicht angeguckt amd das hatten wir gerade schon
amd pbs haben wir noch pc express configuration irgendwelche krassen
abkürzungs dinger die ehrlich gesagt für mich nicht so aussehen als will ich die
editieren am besten sind online usv online usv sind ich hatte vorhin online
usv sind gar nicht mal so toll zumindest bei meine nicht denn als bei
Bei Online-USVs geht der Strom ja immer, oder die Stromversorgung immer durch die Batterie.
Das heißt, wenn du die Batterie austauschen willst oder wenn deine Batterie kaputt geht, gehen auf einmal deine Geräte nicht mehr.
Und du hast dadurch eine längere Downtime als ohne.
Also es hat nicht alles nur Vorteile.
So, wir haben jetzt beides angeklickt hier.
Hier, ne?
Grafics Configuration.
Special Display Hybrid Graphics.
Chatge.
Special Display Features.
Hybrid Graphics.
Also meine Cyberpower ist kaputt gegangen.
Also die Batterie ist kaputt gegangen
und danach lief nichts mehr.
It's for enabling hybrid GPU mode.
Ach so.
Man kann dann beide gleichzeitig aktiv haben für unterschiedliche Monitor oder sowas dann.
Ja gut, das können sie aktivieren, aber ich werde da eh keine External Graphics anschließen.
So, und jetzt gibt es hier unten noch Add-ons.
ok leute da mache ich nichts dran wlan configuration ok da mache ich auch
nichts dran ipv6 network configuration
guck mal der help string ist komplett sinnlos das stimmt überhaupt nicht
das wirkt so als würde der über dhcp konfiguriert dann wenigstens man kann
selbst eine vergeben
aber macht doch standardmäßig dhcp denke also wenn unser px e boot da nicht geht
dann liegt daran und jetzt haben wir als letztes noch driver health der amd gop
Rail Driver.
Phoenix Healthy.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung, ey.
Ich lasse da aber die Finger von
und stelle da nichts dran rum.
Okay.
Also.
Dann mal.
Reboot.
Und jetzt booten wir PXE.
Und installieren Proxmox.
Oh, ich bin doof.
Ich habe PXE-Boot.
Gar nicht als erster Stelle.
Ups.
Ja.
Nochmal, nochmal rebooten.
Auf.
Hallo, warum checkt...
Der checkt mein Escape nicht?
Was ist denn das?
Probier mal das BBS-Boot-Menü aus.
Für PXE. Kann ich auch machen.
Du hast recht.
Das wäre eigentlich sehr...
Der schlau wenn ich wenn ich schaffe da rein zu wechseln weil irgendwie gerade mag meine tastatur nicht
Mit der fac alter kvm please okay ich habe eine idee was man auf
Das spart gerade rum ist ja was wir machen mal
Aber der tippt doch hier.
Exit.
Ach, jetzt bootet er PXE.
Ist ja auch geil.
Hups, falscher Knopf.
So kann man auch PXE booten.
Alles gut, alles klar.
Top.
So.
Also.
Wir wollen jetzt...
Was wollen wir? Proxmox installieren.
heißt im Endeffekt wir gehen in netboot xyz
so linux network installs
ich glaube ich habe eingeführt die Musik ist zu laut
ne Musiklautstärke passt oder?
oder soll ich ein bisschen leiser machen?
1 können wir können vielleicht ein step leiser machen so jetzt perfekt
stopp ok roxmox roxmox v 9.1 text mode wir machen hier keinen kleinen gui stellt oder so
so jetzt muss man warten bis das geladen ist
ist halt deswegen habe ich so sachen die netto txt drin sind trotzdem sowas wie
mit und cash beispielsweise auch bei mir in meinem pxe boot drin weil es einfach
schneller geht wenn man das öfters guten will als jedes mal sich die graben aus
mitternacht zu ziehen
wie hast du gepeilt für das n5 er ich kann es nicht genau sagen so 500 550
Euro so irgendwie in dem Drehen.
540. Irgendwie sowas.
Oder sogar noch weniger.
Weil ich glaube, es gab hier irgendwie
einen 120 Euro Voucher.
Wenn du über den ihre Webseite
bestellst. Ich gucke mal.
Ich gucke mal kurz. Das ist, der Preis
ist wirklich top dafür.
Hier, N5R.
Warte mal, wo habe ich bestellt?
Habe ich bei denen direkt bestellt oder habe ich
bei Amazon bestellt?
Ich habe bei Amazon bestellt.
Einen Tag später gab es keine mehr.
In 5 Luft.
Ja, die über...
Das chinesische Ministerium für Webdesign
hat da ein bisschen verkackt.
Okay, hier sieht man es.
Okay.
Also, 550 kostet es dann.
550.
Und hier gibt es es für 543.
Und hier gibt es das gleiche nochmal ohne Voucher.
Okay, aber das ist theoretisch sogar lieferbar.
Das ist ohne RAM, ohne alles.
Was nicht mehr lieferbar ist, ist das mit 16 GB RAM.
Also 543 Euro gerade bei Amazon.
Na, da kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Das ist ein echt guter Preis für das, was man da an Hardware kriegt.
wieso ist das so teuer ohne alles bin ich gar nicht für das durchaus okay
ihr müsst da nicht 64 oder so reinhauen 32 reicht ja auch mein qr code ich habe
einen amazon ich habe einen amazon link irgendwo fragt mich nicht wo
Amazon Link, ja.
Irgendwo unter den Videos.
Soll ich hinlegen?
Oder auch nicht.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ist wurscht.
Okay, ich seh mal, Leute, ich bin sogar zu dumm,
Reflinks zu posten, ey.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Kauft euch einfach so.
Ähm, ja.
Aber das ist ganz nice.
So, also jetzt erstmal Epoxybox installen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Kenn ich nicht.
Dachte nur, der hat vielleicht einen Amazon-Link.
Aggregale.
Targetdisk.
Jawohl, das ist richtig.
aber wir wollen advanced options zfs raid nicht ausflippen chat zfs raid 0
das ist das einzige was man in dem installer auswählen kann wenn man single
disk setup haben will
compression lz 4 weil es immer noch der schnellste ist checksum klar copies 1
arg max size das passe ich nachher von hand an hdd size moment moment packt er
diese disks damit rein do not use do not use
du sollst es nur hier drauf installieren
Er sollte es nicht auf die anderen...
Raiden Null auf die anderen meiner anderen SSDs machen.
Ja, Andreas.
Ich habe es gerade noch rechtzeitig gesehen.
Ok.
Next.
Äh.
Austria.
Das hatte ich auch noch nicht.
Dass der anhand von meiner...
Wie detecten der...
Detected der das denn?
Äh.
Wo ist denn Germany?
Germany, Europe, Berlin, German. Sehr gut.
Mir gefällt das übrigens im Proxmox-Installer sogar besser als im Debian-Installer.
Da ist immer so ein Akt, das alles auszuwählen.
Next. Okay, Root-Passwort.
Ganz super kompliziert das.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Mail.
Mail at...
Mach LKW, Peter.
Nee, das mache ich nicht, weil das
vergesse ich dann wieder.
Mail-Ad, wie war das?
Preisschamp.org
Moin, habt ihr ein Wortlet?
Jetzt bist du mit Cashy nicht zufrieden?
Nee, das sind ja so ganz andere Kiste.
cash us habe ich auf meinem mini pc installierten das ist der licht auf
warmes aber danke für den zap example punkt kommen ok next pvp example punkt
ip-adresse 2.51 da weiß ich dass die frei ist 2.51 dns server 50 warum holt er sich das eigentlich
nicht über den über der cp moment ist das die richtige netzwerkkarte er moment er 169 das muss
Zierlichreden eine richtige Netzwerkkarte sein.
Ich habe die andere disabled.
Ah, ich glaube, der Treiber heißt einfach nur
R8169, weil die
Netzwerkkarte heißt R8127.
Ne, du hast recht. Gateway ist falsch.
So.
Next.
Install.
Ja, das ist der Driver für die ganzen Realtek-Dinger unter Linux.
Früher war das so, da gab es so extra Realtek-Schichten für Linux.
Die gab es dann parallel, quasi den offiziellen Driver und den Realtek-Dinger.
Weird Champ.
Aber eine Sache, eine gute Sache haben wir da schon gesehen.
Der Kernel ist definitiv neu genug, dass der meine recht neue Netzwerkkarte erkennt.
wieso hat ein router so eine wire adresse mittendrin ist der folgenden grund ursprünglich
war mal folgendes geplant meine ganzen services mit statischen ips kriegen 1 bis 49 das geld
kriegt 50 und darüber gibt es DHCP.
Warum ich mir gedacht habe, dass das eine gute Idee ist,
weiß ich nicht so genau.
Das war so als Trenner gedacht.
Also ich weiß, worunter...
Aber ehrlich gesagt benutze ich das mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
Hast du mittlerweile Glasfaser?
Nee.
Und wahrscheinlich, wenn einer bei mir ausbaut,
dann ist es die Telekom.
Und zur Telekom würde ich auch nicht gehen,
weil Telekom gerade richtig krass abkackt.
Zumindest bei
Cloudflat-Traffic,
also quasi beim halben Internet.
Okay, so.
Startet das jetzt?
Startet das verdammte Spiel.
Ja, das sieht auch gut aus.
Proxmox Virtual Environment.
ZBM müssen wir dann auch installieren.
Wobei ich das auch über
über
PXE laden kann. So, da sind wir.
51, also
2.51
51?
Was?
8.006?
Oh nein.
Ein nicht gültiges Zertifikat.
Sarah von der Telekom hat so einen krassen Schild.
Sarah ist vom Twitter-Support, oder?
Ganz ehrlich, Sarah will den Leuten nur helfen.
Die kann doch auch nichts dafür,
dass die Entscheidungen managementmäßig so scheiße sind.
und vpn hilft ja vpn hilft ja auch wirklich aber es liegt daran dass die telekom sagt
oder war es irgendwas was ich verpasst habe
ok passwort ruht 123456789 okay das erste was man bei proxmox machen muss
ist,
wie gesagt, ich habe nicht viel Ahnung
von Proxmox, aber ein bisschen habe ich damit schon
rumgespielt. Das erste,
was ich immer mache,
bei Proxmox ist,
es gibt hier
so ein Skript
für ein paar
Standardsachen
auf Proxmox.
Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, das standardmäßig
zu installieren und darüber den Rest zu
machen also nicht den rest die ganzen user skripts benutze ich da gar nicht von aber ich finde es an
sich vom menü her und von dem was es für ein macht eigentlich nice was natürlich wieder ein bisschen
fragwürdig ist es lasst uns einfach hier auf 19 die kiste den kram in acht becken aber das machen
wir jetzt einfach okay als telekom status es kann mit einer vpn verbindung funktionieren also dass
sie dafür einen Shitstorm kriegt. Die hat
doch recht. Die hat doch wirklich
recht. Das ist so. Die will den Leuten
nur helfen.
Die will den Leuten doch nur helfen.
Die kann doch nichts dafür, dass die Telekom so scheiße ist.
Das funktioniert ja auch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Rage baitet.
Ich glaube, die will den Leuten wirklich einfach nur
helfen.
Das funktioniert ja auch wirklich.
okay was für eine ip hat nur 51 ssh root 51
123456789 als erstes mal ssh copy id sondern das geben wir mal hier aber was anderes an ssh
wir nehmen jetzt die aus irgendwelchen gründen passt das nicht kommen erst erst
der fonds aussehen wird der fonds immer der von 2010 der rsa key
schau mal bei github rückt was bash club
Was ist das denn?
Bash Club Getra.
Nobody talks about Bash Club.
Proxmox ZFS Post Install.
Okay, hat auch sowas.
ZFS Sync.
Post Install.
Aha.
ab 2.3 autosnap schon das will ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht automatisch installiert haben den cash
den passen passe ich selbst an das macht mir glaube ich ein bisschen zu viel wir machen jetzt
den ja ich finde das menü eigentlich ganz nah ist so englisch wir installieren ganzen mist also
einmal für setup mache ich das danach verwende ich auch so gut wie nicht mehr und er macht lockt
was ich ganz praktisch finde weil das ist ja das ist eine recht billig china
chinesen ssd worauf das jetzt installiert ist und wer weiß nicht dass
die mir in drei jahren wegen täglichem minimal lockt aufkommen kaputt geht
ab die erfahrung mit von ihrer sagt mir gar nichts
die sind auch telekom also ich kenne nur bei der telekom kenne ich nur komster
das ist das ist ja quasi das mobilfunk billig ding von der telekom und ansonsten
keine ahnung von ihrer habe ich schon nie gehört
so jetzt hier menü
hat mit dns absolut nichts zu tun die weil die dns auflösung also egal ob
jetzt in den dns von google verwendet oder den von der telekom das sollte ja auf die gleiche
ip auflösen und daran entscheidet sich welche route dann traffic geht und nicht anhand vom dns
Menü.
Okay.
So, Settings Postinstall.
Automated Postinstall Script.
Bam.
Yes.
Do you want to proceed with system update?
Was, uninstalltes?
Aha.
Viele haben VPN-Blocker aktiv.
Ich habe noch nie gehört, dass irgendwie im großen Stil ein Provider VPNs blocken würde.
Vielleicht ging das ja auch voll an mir vorbei und ich leb auf dem Mond.
Aber ist mir nicht bekannt.
Macht ja auch keinen Sinn.
ich meine die leute müssen sich auf die arbeit verbinden
das ist ja das nächste das ist ja das nächste
du kannst die standard vpn ports vielleicht blocken das wäre aber auch
unsinnig und ansonsten man kann sicherlich den traffic analysieren und
rausbekommen mit recht hoher wahrscheinlichkeit dass das vpn traffic
ist aber du kannst ja vpn und die meisten leute werden auch vpn für ganz
legitime sachen einsetzen zum beispiel auf die auf die auf die arbeit zu
verbinden was die ns beim für ich sag doch nix nix
Es gibt eine Liste mit IPs.
Ach, du meinst die üblichen VPN-Server von den üblichen VPN-Anbietern?
Also, das habe ich zumindest noch nicht gehört, dass das im großen Stil in Deutschland passiert.
So, äh...
Yes?
log to ram
requires a reboot
do you want to restart now
äh
wo wir jetzt restarten
no
ok er hat alles
alles installiert
restart machen wir gleich
was wir jetzt noch machen ist
gehen wir nochmal hier in settings
und schalten dieses komische
Monitor Menü ab
das braucht man nicht. So, fertig.
Cancel
und Steuerung C und jetzt
Reboot.
Dann sind wir top aktuelle
Proxmox-Installationen.
Ach.
Das ist doch Dings hier.
Raspberry Pi Cloud
heißt er doch auf YouTube, oder?
Du bist gerade das erste Mal hier.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Oh, Seven, Chat.
Ich bin letztens über einen Post von ihm gestolpert.
Das ist jetzt aber auch schon ziemlich so nitpicky, ja.
Jeder schreibt mal irgendwas, was verkehrt ist
und zeigt mir ja nicht meine alten Videos,
was ich da teilweise für Mist erzähle.
Ich bin letztens über einen Blogpost von ihm gestolpert,
wo er über irgendwelches ZFS-Caching schreibt.
Das war vollkommen falsch.
Da ging es irgendwie darum, dass ZFS SSD Write Buffer unterstützt und solche Dinger.
Das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Macht ja ZFS nicht.
Also, auf SSDs.
ZFS Write Buffer geht immer erstmal direkt in den RAM.
Was geht ist, du kannst einen Write Buffer für Sync Zugriffe machen und du könntest
extra pool oder die pool ist falsch in der extra device machen für zfs metadata aber
einen white cash im eigentlichen sinne gibt es bei zfs nicht auf er sind in ssd white cash
das ist jetzt das ist wirklich rage ich habe in allen videos erzählt ich halte
davon nichts das video wirst du mir zeigen
Da sind wir wieder am Start. Da sind wir. Guck mal, jetzt haben wir auch sogar eine hübsch gefärbte Shell.
Das sieht doch gleich viel nicer aus.
Bunte Shell, jetzt kann eigentlich nicht mehr schief gehen.
Was steht denn in einer Forward-Datei?
Proxmox Mail Forward.
Also ich bin ein bisschen planlos aus dem Kopf, wenn es um ZFS geht, weil ich es nicht
so oft benutze.
Aber wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, das ist ja nur sinnvoll für synchrone Ride Access
und nicht pauschaler Ride Access, weil die meisten Zugriffe sind ja keine synchronen
oder bringe ich jetzt durcheinander oder ich weiß nur zfz unterstützt keine ssd
right cashes so wie man sich vorstellt so nach dem motto ist das nicht wie cash fs oder sowas
Aber nicht für
Write Access.
Da bin ich mir relativ
sicher, ZFS kann kein
Write Caching außerhalb
vom RAM.
Was geht ist, das aufzusplitten,
dass die Metadaten auf
eine andere Platte gehen.
Dass du beispielsweise auf Festplatten schreibst
und die Metadaten auf eine SSD schreiben lässt.
Oder Sync-Schreibzugriffe,
aber keine normalen asynchrone Rides.
Passt mal auf.
Wir gucken das jetzt nach.
Zill S-Log.
Genau.
What the fuck?
Das ist eine doofe Seite.
Wie hast du das...
Guck hier, genau, hier, das meine ich.
Synchronous Rights.
Siehst du? Das ist das, was ich meine.
Is a component in ZFS
that safely enhances
synchronous rights.
Synchronous Rights, genau.
das bringt ordentlich performance für datenbanken zum beispiel oder halt
sachen wo die anwender explizit sache will sind schreiben aber die meisten
die meisten sachen sind ja keine synchronis rights
und es geht in den ramm
die lösung für die netzwerkkarte noch gefunden also halbe halbe also es sei ihre frau konnte
ich einschalten ich habe dann gestern abend auf stream noch eine ipx efi rom geflasht auf
die netzwerkkarte hat aber auch nicht funktioniert letztendlich die netzwerkkarte schrott ich habe
jetzt mittlerweile ausgebaut und jetzt probieren wir mal und das war jetzt wollte deswegen bin ich
kann überlegen die ganze zeit was müssen wir machen jetzt probieren wir mal aus wie schnell
die netzwerkkarte hier drin ist die on board netzwerkkarte erst mal update wie wir haben
schon geupdatet gerade also dann installieren jetzt erstmal tools die wir also brauchen h top
T-Mux, Fio brauchen wir bestimmt, IPav3, was braucht man sonst noch so da?
Wim, Wim, definitiv Wim.
Noch was für ZFS zeige ich mal her. Ich glaube den kenne ich, ich glaube den kenne ich, den Artikel.
ja was ist das ist aus log drive to your head pool synchronous operations genau dass das freund
gemeint habe was die mission ist die mission ist erstmal zu testen wie gut die on board
netzwerkkarte ist er die public server die hinter cloud verliegen du meinst für die telekom
Ne, kenn ich keinen
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es Leute gibt, die wirklich
Public IPath Cyber Server betreiben
Ähm
No, das will ich nicht automatisch starten
Es gibt Leute, die Public IPath Cyber Server
Wirklich?
Wollen die
Wollen die arm werden
Vom Traffic her oder was haben die vor?
wollen wollen die wollen die hier pippo bernmann machen für dem leben nicht auf
die idee kommen public ipv3 server zu betreiben also schon mal beta probiert
ja mag ich nicht hart ob beste
Chat, jetzt dürft ihr mal entscheiden.
Jetzt, ihr dürft entscheiden.
H-Top, was macht IPath, damit kannst du die Bandbreite von deiner Netzwerkverbindung testen.
Letztendlich brauchst du einen IPath-Server und einen IPath-Client und das schickt einfach so schnell er kann TCP-Pakete.
Und misst, wie schnell es ist.
Also, hier
H-Top, der Klassiker, mittlerweile auch
mit IO-Stats, das gibt's noch gar nicht so lang
Und jetzt kommt B-Top
Ich find das Ding krass
Overload, überladen
Das erste, was ich machen muss, ist
Äh, guck mal
Wenn ich das schon sehe, Alter
Das erste, was ich machen muss, ist
Hier immer Dings umstellen
Äh
Color Theme
Hier
Oh, das kommt jetzt direkt aus dem Teil.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde das so krass
überladen.
BPtop.
Ist, ist, ist,
ist Btop nicht
eine Weiterentwicklung von
BPytop?
rs2 ist praktisch das wäre auch gleich mal für die cpu ausprobieren das man auch installieren
wenn ich gpu metriken brauche dann installiere ich nv top
jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken wir haben wir was haben wir hier
noch? Search. Wie heißt dieses Ding? B-Pi-Top? Wir installieren das jetzt auch nochmal. So.
Jetzt können wir alles vergleichen. Ich alle installieren kann dann auch gleich schon wieder.
B-Pi-Top. Ja doch! Sag ich doch! Das B-Top ist eine Weiterentwicklung davon. Relativ sicher.
Sieht doch eigentlich schon sehr ähnlich aus.
Purge.
Abt Auto Remove.
Welche davon sind written in Rust? Ich habe keine Ahnung was Btop written ist.
Source in C, ja. C++.
also ich bin h top enjoy ganz ehrlich und was ich was ich auch mag ist das hat gerade am chat
jemand vorgeschlagen das ist auch praktisch für cpu geschichten ja sensors kann man auch
senden kann man auch verwenden aber ganz hier das ist nicht verkehrt hier kann man jetzt einfach
sagen hier ich will mal stress ist nicht stress brauchen wir auch noch für bench nicht für bench
für mal auslassen und gucken ob es nicht abkackt hier kann ich jetzt beispielsweise sagen mach mal
stress auf allen hier sieht man guck mal hier sieht man auch die temperatur mach mal stress
auf alle cpu kerne und jetzt wird das ding gleich deutlich wärmer und der lüfter geht hoch der
Lüfter gehen ordentlich rauf.
Hier, TC, das ist die CPU-Temperatur.
Was ich in meinem Home-Netzwerk getan...
Könnte ich tatsächlich machen, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum er für Stress
NG braucht
So, so sieht das
So sieht das dann aus, jetzt kann man das Ding stress testen
Aber ganz ehrlich, ansonsten
Wisst ihr, was auch ganz gut ist?
man macht sich hier einfach hart ob auf hier und macht man sie erst hier auf so
und jetzt hast du alles auf einmal was du brauchst und hier oben siehst du
schöne auslastung stress läuft ganz ehrlich b top ist mir einfach zu
overload overloaded das geht auch voll klar so
Okay, also.
Ich wollte jetzt einfach mal eine 10 Gigabit-Verbindung
testen. Also.
IPav3 minus
10... minus
148. Bam!
Ah!
Nicht
ganz so geil wie meine
andere Netzwerkkarte.
Also das geht schon.
Mal gucken, wie es in die andere
Richtung geht.
andere richtung ist schneller
Andere richtung ist schneller
Aber ganz ehrlich ja ich hätte gerne 0,6 gigabit mehr in die richtung
Aber
Will ich dafür wirklich den PCI-Express-Slot opfern?
Mehr Stromverbrauch und überhaupt MTU?
Da werde ich nichts dran drehen.
Wir können mal gucken.
Das wird Standard sein.
Was ist ein Standard?
1492 oder sowas?
Gucken wir mal.
ETH-Tool.
ETH-Tool NIC 0.
Ne, was war das?
Leute, ich habe DSL-Geschichten durcheinander gebracht.
Standardmäßig 1500.
Bei DSL nach außen hin war es 1492, damit das PPOE-Zeug noch dabei passt.
MTU ist, wie groß dein Ethernet-Frame ist.
So, meine Netzwerkkarte hat gesyncht mit 10 Gig.
Klein besser als groß?
Ne, große MTU kannst du mehr übertragen
logischerweise, ja
Also wenn du jumbo Frames hast
9000 MTU oder sowas
da passt halt einfach mehr Daten rein
Aber Standard ist 1500
und das sollte man, wenn man nicht wirklich
gute Gründe für hat
auch so lassen
Und das müssen dann aber auch
alle Geräte im Netzwerk so eingestellt sein.
Deswegen, da stelle ich nichts dran rum.
Das bleibt 1500.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja noch irgendwelche Tuning-Options
für die Netzwerkkarte.
Der Speed ist jetzt
schon nicht so richtig geil,
aber ich finde,
es geht klar. Für eine Onboard-Netzwerkkarte,
die
auch noch ziemlich neu ist
und sicherlich noch nicht den advancedesten
Treiber hat.
Du meinst, ich soll mal mehrere
Dinger starten?
Ne, es ist nicht P.
Ist es nicht?
Warte mal, wie macht man das?
I have 3 multiple streams.
Groß P.
P4.
Nee, bei 8,8 ist Schluss.
Wer macht da nicht?
Juckt den nicht
Wollen wir uns parallel dazu
Das können wir tatsächlich machen
Warten wir mal
Wir können uns parallel dazu mal die CPU
Die CPU-Laut angucken
Nix
Das juckt den überhaupt nicht
Ne, ich glaube die Netzwerkkarte kriegt einfach nicht mehr hin
Oder beziehungsweise die Netzwerkkarte
in Kombination mit dem Treiber kriegt einfach nicht mehr hin.
Die Gegenseite kriegt mehr hin.
Das haben wir ja ausprobiert vorhin.
Guck, wenn ich auf die gleiche Kiste
von Windows aus
einen iPerf mache.
Eben war es doch noch schneller.
Ja, ja, guck, jetzt ist es schneller.
9,5.
und reverse ok ok also haben wir es der ist reverse ein bisschen langsamer keine ahnung
das wird schon passen ja es geht auf jeden fall ein bisschen schneller aber der ist bei 8 85 mach
mal windows n5 ok ipad 3 minus s 51
9,5 und jetzt die andere kiste zur windows kiste gleich andere richtung
Das ist noch schlechter.
Oh, das ist noch langsamer.
Oder auch nicht.
Das ist ich nicht so ganz sicher.
Aber 8,8, mehr schafft die Netzwerkkarte
nicht.
Aber das hängt wieder an der Stelle.
Guckt.
Das schwankt
auch ein bisschen, ne?
Na 10 GIG kriegste nicht.
9,4, 9,5 ist schon top.
Also ich würde sagen, das ist ein Problem der Netzwerkkarte bzw. des Treibers in Kombination.
Aber ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, das geht in Ordnung.
Das ist Mario Kart, irgendeine Mario Kart Strecke.
Mushroom Gorge.
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie Secret of Mana Musik.
Okay, wir können ja mal Google fragen.
R8127 Linux Performance Tuning.
Wir können sehen, ob wir was auf Layer 1 verlieren, weil Retry 0. Wir verlieren nichts.
Hier werden die Retries stehen.
Guck mal, wenn ich jetzt sag, hier, ich mach 99 Prozesse, dann wird dir gleich auffallen.
Guck, ich hab Retries. Siehste?
Oder wahrscheinlich reichen da 8 schon.
8 Parallele, 10 Gigstreams. Ne, reichen nicht.
12 Parallele, 10 Gigstreams. Reichen auch noch nicht.
48 Parallele.
Okay, guck, da hast du Retries. Siehste?
daran siehst du ob du was unten drunter verlierst
und ich habe keinerlei retransmissions das ist limitierung netzwerkkarte
schrägstrich kombination mit dem treiber wir können jetzt natürlich
habe ich kein kappa emote
warum habe ich kein kappa im ort brauche ich zu selten oder was ich wollte gerade
sagen wir könnten ja auch windows installieren und damit mal testen
so gibt es irgendwie
Ist das dazu irgendwas?
Achso, das können wir tatsächlich nochmal gucken.
Ist gar keine schlechte Sache.
Äh, ETH-Tool minus I.
Können wir mal schauen.
Hier, Driver, Kernel-Version.
Äh, Firmware-Version.
Vielleicht gibt es eine neuere Firmware-Version.
Kann man das Ding überhaupt
Firmware upgraden?
Oder ist das Bestandteil vom Treiber?
Realtek?
R816
Ah, das ist der andere.
Gibt es da?
Okay, warte mal.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Gibt es da eine neue Firmware vielleicht für?
Ich glaube, die kann man wahrscheinlich gar nicht flashen.
Nee, okay.
Die ist...
Ah, Chat.
Wir könnten...
Okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Einfach nur, um das mal auszuprobieren.
Nee, BIOS-Update gibt es dafür noch ganz...
Ich habe eine Idee.
Was wir mal ausprobieren könnten ist, wir laden uns den offiziellen Treiber runter und kompilieren den und gucken mal, wie schnell es damit ist.
Was haltet ihr davon? Einfach nur mal gucken, was das aktuelle Maximum ist, was denn zur Zeit die Karte unterstützt und kann.
Hier, guckt mal, vom 30.07.
Also ich werde das aber nicht benutzen, sage ich gleich.
flipper kollege von mir auf der arbeit hat so einen flipper zero und er hat
letztens damit festgestellt man kriegt unsere schränke auf auch ohne karte mit
dem teil okay das ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen neuer als das hier alles
also laden wir das mal runter
So ein Akt wie gestern werde ich bestimmt nicht machen.
Wget.
Da müssen wir aber gleich per
KVM drauf.
Weil wenn ich den Netzwerktreiber
unloade, wird es natürlich schwierig
per SSH drauf zu sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Kampgram.
Wget.
Minus O.
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
BZ2 war das. Ich hab doch diesen
Und kam gestern auch schon nicht mehr runtergeladen, oder?
Oh ne, das geht ja nicht.
Ich kack, Noob.
Das geht ja nicht.
Man muss ja erst einmal wieder
Captchas lösen.
P?
Was ist das?
HX49.
Submit.
Copy, Download, Link.
TabZ2.
Weget.
Ich habe doch gestern schon geguckt, wie man BZ2 entpackt.
Hier.
Nice.
So, da sind wir.
Also.
So, apt install build essentials.
Das sollte man vielleicht auch im Proxmox Host alles nicht machen, aber weiß drauf.
Und wir installieren mal Kernel Headers.
Wie heißen die denn unter Proxmox?
Apt search, irgendwas mit PVE Header, glaube ich.
Ja, PVE Headers.
Lokale? Es gibt schon lange KI, die Captchas, also noch vor KI gab es KI, die Captchas löst.
Deswegen wurden die Dinger ja auch immer abgedrehter.
Mittlerweile hast du ja teilweise Captchas, ähm, erkenne die Hydranten, dann geh raus, zähl die nächsten 5 Blätter auf der Straße, renn 3 mal ums Haus und dann musst du sagen, äh, welche Form die dritte Wolke von links hat.
So, okay, dann darfst du rein.
Make.
Okay, wir haben installiert.
Make, Install.
Gibt es Make Uninstall eigentlich?
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Versau ich halt ein bisschen mein
Virtualisierungshaus.
ok user lib modules
rap r 81 da ist es ok dann müssen wir jetzt allerdings hubs dann müssen wir das hier mal
per KVM drauf.
Weil ich kann kaum
meinen Netzwerkkartentreiber unloaden, während
ich bei SSH drauf bin.
Modprobe minus R. Wie hieß das Ding?
R 1 8
Ne. 6 9.
Ja.
Ich mach mal ein bisschen größer.
Okay.
IP Add.
Netzwerkkarte ist aus.
Dann machen wir jetzt Modprobe
R 8 1
2 7.
funktioniert und jetzt haben wir hier eine netzwerkkarte die ist da meinetwegen ip link
nick 0 ab moment ich muss sie war ich muss sie zur bridge hätten wie ging das noch mal
rich ctl oder if at if vor allem 0 wobei nick 0 gibt es jetzt doppelt ich mache es
lieber von Hand.
IP link
show
ne, IP link
nick 0
up
Ne, set
set. Ah, das vergesse ich immer.
Und jetzt?
IP ist up.
Okay.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Geht das
Geht das jetzt wieder?
Ne, ne?
Ne.
Ähm.
Okay, also dann doch.
Äh.
Brühe CTL
Add if
Vmbr 0
Nick 0. Okay.
Jetzt müsste er wieder funktionieren.
Jawoll, da sind wir wieder.
Ach, hier oben geht es auch wieder.
Okay, und jetzt haben wir auch hier
den Treiber geladen.
Jetzt jetzt schaue chat was mein ihr ist das mit dem offiziellen treiber
deutlich schneller als mit dem linux kernel treiber
Also ich persönlich tippe drauf es ist ein bisschen ein ganz kleines bisschen schneller
Aber nicht so dass man sagen würde man zieht das vor mit manuellem kompilieren
Manche meinen sogar langsamer
Okay, probieren wir mal.
Hi, Perf.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist exakt genauso schnell.
Das ist exakt genauso schnell.
Kein Unterschied.
Welchen Stuhl ich benutze?
Ich benutze einen Mr.
24 von Sedus.
Bester Stuhl ever. Bester Stuhl, den ich je hatte.
Das einzige Problem bei dem Stuhl
ist, dass es, dass er teuer ist.
Den kann man sich mal
gönnen, wenn man viel vorm Rechner
arbeiten, damit auch sein Geld verdient.
Aber so 1.300, 1.400
Euro muss man schon rechnen für den Stuhl.
Aber da ist Pock. Der ist besser als
alle anderen Stühle, die ich kenne. Und den habe ich
jetzt auch schon jahrelang und der ist noch wie neu.
Der ist einfach auch mega stabil.
Ich kenne den aus dem Büro. Mein alter Arbeitgeber
hatte auch Sedos Stühle.
Und
daher kannte ich den. Hat mir gedacht, den hole ich auch
daheim.
Wieso diese Dinger?
weil die saumäßig gut sind ok leute es hat sich nichts also wirklich 0, nichts bewegt die werte
sind exakt das gleiche wirklich exakt das gleiche zwischen dem treiber und dem anderen treiber der
speed ist stabiler ich weiß nicht dass biet macht überhaupt keinen unterschied das ist das genau das
gleiche 9,41 hat man vorher auch weniger schwankung ok chat mod probe minus rr 8127
Mordprobe R8196
Äh
Nicht?
Okay
Ab
Und sind wir wieder da?
Wir sind wieder da.
So, gleiches noch einmal.
Jetzt ist exakt das gleiche.
Das ist jetzt der andere Treiber.
Es ist wirklich...
Null Unterschied. Gar kein Unterschied.
Absolut gar kein Unterschied
zwischen den beiden Treibern.
gibt es gibt es nicht irgendwie make an install oder sowas install clean install ok ok also dass
das bringt nichts dass das macht keinen sinn also die macht also da braucht man nicht den
den treiber den den treiber vom hersteller zu verwenden aber gibt es vielleicht eine
firma eine neue firma die überflächen können vielleicht liegt sie auch daran
irgendwo ja download aber die firma ist bestandteil vom treiber wahrscheinlich
das heißt es wird sich mit der zeit an updaten
Was, was, was ist, was?
8, 1, 2, 6
Firmware? Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Ah, das ist die 5 Gig.
Das ist der 5 Gig Treiber.
Ne, ne, wir haben den 10 Gig Treiber.
Es gibt aber keine Firmware zu flashen hier.
Das...
Äh...
Nix, was ich flashen will, oder?
Wartungsfenster, wo? Wie viel?
Ich hab übrigens gelesen, die Connex 4 werden auch bald entfernt.
Also, das werde ich mir nicht mehr holen.
da kann man aktuell nichts machen 18 ist mit so teuer wenn ich einfach meine
onboard nick verwenden kann ok also chat da können wir nichts machen
da kann man nichts machen also mehr werden wir da nicht raus kriegen
Max, hast du das mit Asus und Acer mitbekommen wegen Nokia?
Nee.
Was machen die?
Was machen die so?
Okay, ich wollte ja noch mal kurz hier gucken,
ob es da irgendwelche Tuning-Sachen gibt.
ETH.
Ah ja, ob irgendwelche Offloadings an oder aus sind.
Das können wir tatsächlich mal kurz gucken.
eth tool minus k ok wir füllt dann alles raus was fix ist fix bedeutet bei eth eth tool ist
quasi fest so in der firma kann man nicht ändern so dass hier sind quasi sachen die man ändern kann
man kann die cp segmentation da wird nicht segmentiert das brauchen wir nicht keine ahnung
was das ist. Keine Ahnung. Hier, das sind die Standard-
Dinger. Das ist okay.
Ansonsten haben wir nur noch
TX No Cache Copy.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
RX FCS, RX All
und RX
Rohlist.
Okay.
Das fragen wir jetzt mal.
Ob, mal gucken ob die AI das ordentlich explainen kann.
Was?
Acer und Asus, Gericht untersagt PC und Laptop Vertrieb in deutsch. What? Was?
Acer, meine Oma
Also so lange gibt es Acer schon, ja. Meine Oma hat das noch mitgekriegt. Meine Oma hat immer gesagt Archer, Archer.
Nicht Acer.
Archer, Archer hat die gesagt, Archer. Genau, Archer.
Nicht Archer, Archer.
Archer.
Aha.
Moment, bestimmte Notebooks verletzen ein Patent von Nokia.
H.265, Alter, dieses dumme Video-Encoding-Patent-Kacke da.
Das hatten wir um H.264 auch schon.
Oh, mal Acer.
Äh, uns.
Okay, also die AI erklärt uns jetzt.
Diese Funktion versucht die CPU Caches zu umgehen, indem Daten aus dem User Space direkt in den Hauptspeicher geschrieben werden.
dma um cash verschmutzung zu vermeiden sie ist oft werden dann ganz normal über den cash kopiert
dies ist oft die stabilere standardeinstellung das umgehen des caches bei tunnel protokoll die
performance sogar verschlechtern kann verlassen wir uns auf die erklärung wie ok battle explain
bestimmt ob die frame check sie können am paket erhalten bleibt wenn es an das system weiter
gegeben wird
ok
eine variante von generisch offload sie bündelt mehrere kleine empfang der
pakete einer verbindung zu einer liste bevor sie an den netzwerk stark übergeben
werden wenn sie oft ist finde ich speziell ist
bündel nicht statt
udp pakete ok also probieren wir mal ich
habe wirklich keinen platz ich habe ich
habe mein leben noch nicht an
netzwerkkarten parametern umgedreht ja
also keine ahnung ob das was bringt
also schalten wir jetzt mal xr gru list
ein und tx no cash copy der reihe nach
jetzt schauen wir erstmal was chat gibt er dazu sagt ja okay das ist mehr oder
weniger das gleiche klingt auch nicht sinnvoll sehe ich auch so
ich halte es ja auch zu selbst dies options with eth tool
minus groß k interface feature auf ok dann dann machen wir das mal wir probieren es einfach mal
aus eth tool minus groß k jetzt bricke ich erstmal meine onboard netzwerkkarte nick 0
Wie war das hier kann 0 und jetzt feature on off also welches feature habe ich gesagt tx no cash copy
Okay, und jetzt ipad
Chat
Ich würde sogar sagen einen ganz kleinen tick langsamer als vorher
ganz kleinen tick nur kein unterschied kein unterschied kein unterschied ein unterschied
dann setzen wir das wieder auf off und was hat man noch rx kro list auf
ConnectX 175 Euro.
Ich brauche keine Netzwerkkarte, aber vielleicht will ja einer aus dem Chat.
So.
TX.
Wie heißt die Playlist? Das ist in Mario Kart.
Mario Kart Music for Studying Fast.
perf
chat macht absolut keinen unterschied diese options null unterschied macht macht überhaupt nichts aus
ok jetzt will ich aber noch mal was ausprobieren stellen wir das wieder auf off jetzt probieren
wir noch was aus jetzt machen wir mal absichtlich jetzt machen wir absichtlich
was aus ok nämlich die checksum für ipv4 das sollte jetzt schon das sollte jetzt
schon probleme machen ja
Das sollte jetzt schon Einfluss auf die
IPF macht TCP
Okay, das ist immer noch gleich schnell
Ja gut, ähm, meine CPU ist ja auch schnell genug
Ja doch, doch, doch, guck mal da
Das macht schon einen Unterschied
Das ist schon ein Unterschied
Mach mal UDP
Ja, UDP mag ein bisschen schneller sein
Aber ich hab doch den Vergleich.
Ich hab doch den Vergleich mit meiner Windows-Kiste
TCP
auf den Endpunkt und jetzt mit der Linux-Kiste.
Das kann man ja vergleichen.
Das ist
so 0,3 bis 0,4
Gig.
Das ist ein Unterschied. Aber das ist ja auch nicht schlimm.
Ich find das vollkommen okay, ja.
So.
Wirds was gucken.
Hat er jetzt alles wie vorher eingeschaltet?
bekunde
ja genau er sieht so aus wie vor und on of on on on of on ja alles alles klar und diese
generic dinger waren die vorher auch
von ok moin michael 50 milliarden also jetzt immer wieder wie vorher auch
genauso stellen vor da lässt sich nichts tun also wir sind aktuell so gerade am
limit von der netzwerkkarte und dem treiber unter linux
Aber ganz ehrlich, der
Receive
ist...
Schneller geht's nicht mehr.
Kann man die übertacken.
Und das Senden...
Ja, ich sag mal so, ich hätte schon gerne
so 0,5...
0,5, 0,6
Gig mehr, aber ganz ehrlich, das ist auch
okay. Für das, dass ich keine extra
Netzwerkkarte da reinpappen muss, ist das
durchaus okay.
Wollen wir das mal mit UDP testen?
Weil ihr es seid, Chat.
Ich glaube, da muss man minus U machen.
Nee.
Äh, doch.
Äh, what?
Äh.
Nee, das geht irgendwie anders.
Ähm.
ipad 3 udp das ipad mit udp ist 5 hat was muss ich da muss man auch irgendwas
angeben hier bandwidth hier b 10 g oder auch nicht
Oh, das ist klein g?
Okay, kein Schimmer, wie das funktioniert.
Slash 30, was macht das denn?
Okay.
Chat, ich bin zu dumm für
IPerf zu bedienen.
Test
IPerf 3
10 Gig Performance.
Ja, ja.
Ja, aber das ist TCP, nicht UDP.
Ach, ich habe nicht UDP hingeschrieben.
Äh.
UDP.
B, 10 Gig.
Okay.
Das hatten wir ja gerade
Okay
Whatever Leute, keine Ahnung wie man das ordentlich testet
Es ist schon ein Witz, dass
UDP irgendwie langsamer ist
Nur halb so schnell ist
Wie TCP
Aber was auch immer
Keine Ahnung
Das liegt aber garantiert an mir
Oder aber
Oder aber es ist ein Bug.
Von IPerf.
Keine Ahnung.
Was genau macht das hier?
Komm, wollen wir der AI mal trusten, dass sie weiß, was sie macht?
Mach doch mal den Windows-Test.
Stimmt, ich kann das Ganze von Windows aus machen, ja.
Okay.
Was?
Achso.
Hä, sogar noch langsamer.
Ja, da ist ein Switch dazwischen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das liegt jetzt an Alperf und meinem Rumgebastel, weil TCP hat keine Retransmissions und ist sauschnell.
Also kein Schimmer. Juckt mich auch nicht. Wird schon passen.
Jumbo Frames. Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich das hier mache bei TCP?
Das dürfte eigentlich nichts bringen, ne?
Dürfte ja eigentlich nichts machen.
Nee, sogar langsamer.
Ja gut, das wird jetzt fragmentiert wahrscheinlich.
Was ist, wenn ich eine MTU von 100 mache?
Da geht jetzt quasi nichts drüber.
Ja, nee, das macht keinen Sinn.
Ja, keine Ahnung, wie man UDP gescheit testet mit IPF.
Interessiert mich jetzt aber auch nicht so wirklich.
So, also die Netzwerkkarte ist auf jeden Fall schnell genug.
Ich hätte gerne 0,5 Gig mehr, aber das Gute ist, man kann sich damit bei jedem Linux Kernel Update drauf freuen, dass vielleicht die Performance noch ein Ticken besser wird.
Ist doch schon mal gut.
So.
So Chat, ihr könnt euch jetzt überlegen, was wir als nächstes machen. Wollen wir jetzt eine Open Media Vault VM installieren?
vm installieren für sammer eventuell wenn das sagt ein lxc container oder wollen war lokales
lm darauf laufen lassen mal gucken wie schnell es ist ich bin für lokales lm mal gucken wie schnell
ist das geht auch schnell um vok o m v o m v o m v l l m samba l l m okay wir machen
eh beides chat und wie viel rahmen ich habe zu recht und das geht auch das geht
ja auch relativ schnell der chat hat mir letztens erzählt olama ist out kobold
CPP wäre jetzt voll in.
Kann mir jemand,
Stich halte ich, der das schon ausprobiert hat,
sagen, ob das stimmt.
Macht das Sinn, Kobold-CPP zu verwenden
anstelle von Ulama?
Weil mit Ulama
kenne ich mich zumindest ein bisschen aus.
Außer, dass man hier irgendwelche
Weep-Anime-Sachen machen kann.
Mit Kobold-CPP habe ich keinen
Plassen Schimmer.
Nicht Kobold, Kobold.
gibt's auch gar nicht gibt's lama
unterlagen wir nehmen wir olama
willst du nur text nur bilder will ich nicht generieren
Alter, das hört ja gar nicht mal auf.
Gibt es das hier für Linux?
Cuda, no Cuda.
Ja, okay.
Olamar Linux.
Es geht ja nur um eine Hausnummer, ja.
Erste Mal.
Moment, Moment.
Das machen wir jetzt in einem LXC-Container.
Auf der anderen Seite
chat chat chat kann man in einem lxc container gescheit die grafikkarte durchreichen
also man müsste
keine ahnung
Kann man nicht.
Man kann nur das Device installieren, ja.
Ach komm, ich installiere das...
Genau, man muss DevDI durchreichen.
Sowas habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich nicht meinen Proxmox verunstalten hier,
aber ganz ehrlich, ich reinstalle das später eh.
Also komm, bam, einfach direkt nach SH als Rootpipen.
So wie sich gehört
Auf dem Virtualisierungshost
Als Root Sachen aus dem Internet laden
Und direkt nach SH peiten
So muss das sein
Ihr seid bestimmt schon drin, oder?
Ihr habt bestimmt
Mein DNS gespooft irgendwie
Und auf Ulama ist jetzt euer Server
Der Chat, eigentlich ist es in Wirklichkeit
qchat.com und ich lade gerade
was runter, pipes nach
Hut und der Chat ist am Start.
Jetzt wird mein Server gleich ferngesteuert
vom Chat.
Muss man nicht vorher ein OS auf dem LXC
installieren? Ja.
Also du musst ein Debian Image
beispielsweise starten und sowas.
Okay, wir probieren
GPT-OSS aus.
Äh, 20, 20,
ähm, 20b.
Probieren wir aus.
65 Gigs
vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Es gibt auch fertige Container.
Cool.
muss doch bestimmt irgendwie durchreichen so
olama amd gpu ready ok
jetzt müssen wir kurz warten da machen wir in der zwischenzeit was anderes jetzt müssen wir
erstmal das Model runterladen.
Bin mal gespannt, wie schnell der ist.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich denke mal, wir können den sogar noch
ordentlich beschleunigen.
Ah, Chat, mir fällt noch was ein.
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Ähm.
NV-Top, geht das hier? Ah, okay.
Geht. Also 512
hat die Grafikkarte gerade.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich mach den Container
lieber selbst.
Aber es ist gut,
dass es das gibt.
Wisst ihr, was cool wäre?
Bei diesen ganzen Install-Skripts,
ne?
Warum gibt es nicht auch gleich wieder
einen Uninstall? Das ist fast schon
wie unter Windows. Weil ich habe jetzt
komplett meinen Proxmox schon mit tausend Sachen
versaut so will ich das ja auf dauer auch nicht betreiben also ich muss das
auf jeden fall nachher nochmal reinstallen wenn ich das weiter
verwenden will
das post install habe ich benutzt das post install habe ich aber auch vorher
mit was habe ich tatsächlich vorher mal drüber gescrollt war ich im github ich
habe da vorher mal drüber gescrollt also das war okay aus aber du hast vollkommen
recht das ist hochgradig also hoch risikoreich random scripts da einfach
auszuführen auf seinem virtualisieren also generell auf in der linux kiste aus
dem internet also ich bin da auch kein großer fan von deswegen verwende ich die
ganzen user scripts nicht benutzt das nur zum initial einrichten log to run
finde ich ganz gut aber in der heutigen zeit guck mal wie viel das supply chain
Angriffe es gibt.
Und mit diesen ganzen Skripten,
du lädst dir ja 100.000 Sachen runter.
Wer weiß, wenn da
einer in der Kette mal irgendwas
verkackt hat,
dann hast du irgendeinen Mist drauf. Also,
naja.
Ach, den gibt's nicht mehr?
Oh.
Das sagt.
Will das aber gar nicht wissen.
Die Leute sind alle in meinem Alter irgendwie.
Curl Bash Enjoyer?
Ich bin auch Curl Bash Enjoyer.
Aber nur wenn ich mir, wenn es irgendeine Testkiste ist oder ich mir sicher bin, dass das okay ist, weil ich schon ein paar Mal benutzt habe.
Ach komm, eine Minute dreißig, das warten wir jetzt einfach mal ab.
Also Glasfaser, bei dir kommt es in Zukunft.
Wenn es kommt, dann wahrscheinlich nur von der Telekom.
Und das wird sacken.
Oder mal gucken, wie es mit Cloudflare in der Telekom bis dahin ist
Schauen wir mal
Ich wäre sofort am Start mit
Also ich werde es mir auf jeden Fall
Sobald es das gibt, instant ins Haus legen lassen
Ob ich einen Vertrag abschließe bei der Telekom, sei mal dahingestellt
Aber ich will es auf jeden Fall schon mal haben
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, dass ich dann sage
Och nö, das machen wir nicht
Und drei Jahre später will ich es haben
Und dann müssen wir nochmal die Straße aufreißen
Und das dauert nicht
wie den ich sobald es wirklich einer hier machen will lasse ich mir ins haus legen
Hältst du das neue spiel 8 problem ist wirklich ein spiel
Was ich eigentlich witzig finden würde
Warum heißt das Layer 8 Problem?
Das könnte auch Pep-Kack heißen.
Pep-Kack.
Das heißt,
Problem exists between keyboard and chair.
Also quasi Layer 8 Problem.
Wichtige Informationen.
Oh.
Ja, wenn die Vermieter da nicht mitmachen,
das ist echt dumm.
Gerade, dass es in Zukunft natürlich auch
ein Plus für die Wohnung ist. Aber das juckt
die eh nicht, weil die kriegen eh die Wohnung aus
den Händen gerissen.
So, jetzt können wir mal
Olamar fragen, was das beste
Twitch-Emote ist.
Ja, schick mal den Link.
Sparky, schick mal den Link,
vielleicht können wir das,
weil wir gerade ein bisschen Pause brauchen.
Olamar, willst du nicht was machen?
Nein, nein!
Kack, du, ich hab abgebrochen.
Ah, hier der Olamar Runner macht Dinger.
Du bist der Sysadmin.
Okay, das sieht in der Tat ganz lustig aus, das Game.
Ich speichere mir das mal.
Wenn wir gerade nichts weiter zu tun haben oder Pause machen, dann probieren wir das mal aus.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz witzig.
Okay, da sind wir hier.
Was ist das beste Twitch-Emote?
Boah, das ist ja richtig schnell.
Das flutscht.
Leute, das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Das ist ja richtig zackig.
Aber Grafikkarte wird nicht benutzt, oder?
Ja, dann nutzt man nochmal so.
Das ist aber echt...
Also, du kannst dich nicht beschweren.
Das ist jetzt nicht so schnell wie hier lokal mit LM Studio, wo wir mal laufen hatten und alles.
Aber das ist schon schnell genug.
Schnell genug.
passt ja auch passt ja auch noch alles in ram
abgebrochen ich muss sagen dass er die amd gpu verwenden soll ja guckt er benutzt keine 16 g
graben
ok jetzt macht gpt 5 oder irgendwelche gpt 5 sachen
Quen 3 ist nicht schlecht, das habe ich schon benutzt.
Pogchamp sagt er, dass das beste Emote ist.
Okay, wie sagt man denn
Ulama, dass es die GPU benutzt hat?
Ulama AMD GPU Linux
NV Top
Ey, ganz ehrlich, ich habe kein
lokales Model
gefunden für ordentliches Vibe-Coding
Ich Vibe-Code ja eigentlich in dem Sinn
auch nicht, ich benutze das immer zur Unterstützung
so für kleine Sachen oder hier kann man
das mal schöner machen oder hast du noch eine gute idee oder so was ich weib code
keine ganzen projekte also für so kleine fragen fand ich wenn kohler ganz gut
aber wirklich für wie man so neudeutschland agentic sachen wo das
ding dann aber was machen lassen kannst mit tool usage und was habe ich bisher
kein lokales model gefunden was was taugt also was man auf meiner grafikkarte
auch gut laufen lassen kann ja da benutze ich in letzter zeit glm 4.7
Und Minimax 2.1, weil es das bei OpenCode kostenlos gibt.
Wie sagt man denn, Ulama, dass es AMD-GPU nehmen soll?
Hier Hardware Support.
Rock'em Library hat er installiert.
eine gpu wird nicht unterstützt oder aber kann schon sein
Okay, wie macht man das jetzt?
Render? Was? Render Group?
vor allem die only you may need to add olama zu den rennen
das läuft als gut also das muss funktionieren
das läuft
Warte mal.
Eine Radeon 780M und will die mit Ollama unter Linux benutzen.
Wie geht das?
Ja, das ist aber auch was anderes als Vibe-Coden.
Rock'em Info?
Rock'em? Was ist Rock'em?
Das, das, das, das, das fantasiert wieder.
Wenn GPU genutzt wirst du im Log etwas wie using Rock'em.
Okay.
Sehe ich sowas im Log?
Aha, Debug.
Ollama check if
Rock'em is used
Ollama PS
100% CPU
Aha
Okay also das ist schon mal falsch
rock im info
wie installiert das denn
also
Aha.
Und jetzt?
Hat er es gefunden?
Weiter.
Rock'em SMI.
Was nicht alles gibt.
J-Up-Search, ja alles klar, Max
Ich installiere einfach irgendwelches
Random-Zeug, von dem ich keine Ahnung habe
Okay, macht der jetzt da?
Woran erkenne ich jetzt, dass der
Rock'em
Oh, Lama.
Peckel?
Äh, ähm...
Wo erkenne ich da jetzt überhaupt irgendwas dran?
Das ist doch hier meine CPU, oder?
Olamar sollte Valken nutzen.
Okay.
Olamar 780M.
Aha.
Guck mal, hier ist ein Guide.
780M.
Wie man Hardware beschleunigt, dass Olamo auf einer integrierten GPU wie Radion M unterliegend zum Lauf bringt.
Also.
Für Hardwarebeschleunigung kannst du entweder Rokim oder Valken.
Die Olamo wollen die Valken-Integration nicht merchen, also besser Rokim benutzen, wenn möglich.
Das hat etwas schlechteres, aber ist einfach zu betreiben.
Brauchst du, findest du hier in Vorkipler.
Ich nutze Archinux, aber also Olamo und Rokim.
Ah, okay.
Aha
Okay, also
Das da muss ich setzen
Oh, VRAM
Hab ich nicht gesetzt
Nö, der benutzt keine...
PS?
100% CPU.
Okay, ich muss noch mal ins BIOS und ein bisschen mehr RAM dem Ding geben.
At least...
Okay, ja, kann ich machen.
install gpu drive an rock'em haben wir doch schon install lama die igp so
detektiv und extra steps to enable it warte mal sollte ich vielleicht mal hier
auf master gehen bei the way gerade wo wir dabei sind die page not found
Page not found?
Äh.
Tutorials?
Ja, da ist es doch.
Ah, ne, Moment.
Das ist ja...
Ah, ich kacke.
Docks.
Gut.
So, jetzt gibt es ja mal.
Das ist auch schon ein Jahr her.
Oh, gut.
Lass mal weiter gucken.
Stop the Olamaservice.
Modify the Olamaservice.
Ja, das haben wir ja gerade gemacht.
Ach, Moment.
Da läuft System D.
Moment, das läuft mit.
Ach so.
Hä? Oder auch nicht?
Chat, warum ist das Nano?
Environment.
Hier, da muss was hin?
Ach nee, zu ETC.
Moment.
No, no, no, no.
Ich kann Nano nicht exiten.
Weil ich Ctrl-X gebeindet hab.
Kill all Nano.
Bam.
P-Kill Nano.
Jetzt.
Ah.
Nano.
Läuft nicht?
Äh.
Ist im.
D.
Editor.
Kill.
Was hier los ist?
Versuch grad Olamo auf meinem Lasten
laufen zu bringen.
Weil es geht.
Okay, das soll da rein.
Okay, Restart.
Ulama Service.
Ja, ja, Sudo brauchen wir nicht.
Okay.
Und jetzt Ulama.
GPT.
Ah, jetzt lädt er neu.
das kann natürlich sein dass es eine weile braucht mit gold war auch schon
viele haben vieles gemacht auch im stream schon ich mag go
ich finde mittlerweile nicht
jules rock im smi ja das ding ist nur ich erkenne bei rock im smi ehrlich
gesagt, nix von meiner Grafik.
Ach hier, VRAM Usage Prozent.
Ah.
Daran erkennt man was.
Das da ist das, was man hier sieht, oder?
GPU und VRAM Usage.
Okay.
Okay, wir sollten vielleicht
das da probieren. Das geht dann schneller als
GPT-5.
Ah.
Jetzt GPU-Usage, Leute.
Chat?
Habt ihr irgendeine Idee?
Wie kann man das gescheit benchmarken?
Dass dann am Ende rauskommen
Tokens pro Sekunde und sowas?
Gibt es das?
Ulama Tokens per Second
Benchmark.
Dass man das checken kann?
Benchmarking Tokens per Second.
Ich hab doch mal
einen Artikel gelesen.
Ukraine 4800 plus
plus Olamar.
Da hat doch irgendwie einer was drüber geschrieben.
Wer da?
Ja.
Genau, wie, wo hat er das hier her?
Wo, wo hat er das hier her?
Ist das mit Open Web UI?
Okay.
Olamar Run Model My Prompt.
Also sowas hier.
Kekke.
Okay, vielleicht hätte ich das doch mal in einem Container machen sollen.
Okay, Open Web UI.
Egal, wir installieren die Proxmox Geschichte eh neu dann.
Ist ja durch.
Ich hab hier gelandet.
GitHub.
Releases.
Caution.
Wie installiert man das?
Ist das ein Docker-Container oder?
Docker-Container?
Ah, pip install.
Lama CPP?
Ja, ich mach das jetzt mit OpenWeb UI.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Bam, wir kleistern uns jetzt einfach das System voll.
Wir kleistern uns jetzt voll das System mit.
Bam.
Minus, minus, verbis?
Du meinst bei Olamar oder was?
ach so
oh man ich wollte hier unten hin nv top sie hat mein cursor irgendwie nicht
okay erzieht man dass die gpu was schafft
gpu schafft was
19,2 tokens pro sekunde chat das ist gar nicht mal schlecht also für lokale
gedöns wenn du einfach nur einen paperless paperless ng hast und damit deine dokumente
taggen willst oder so. Das ist vollkommen
ausreichend. Das ist gar nicht mal übel.
Wird es besser, wenn du mehr
RAM vergibst? Das probieren wir. Probieren wir gleich
mal aus.
Nicht sensor watch.
Wir machen mal ein bisschen was längeres, Chat.
Mal ein bisschen was längeres. Was ist das
beste Twitch-Emote?
Schreibe mir
einen Aufsatz mit
mindestens
keine ahnung 500 setzen jetzt sagt jetzt das war random bullshit von sich geben
weil das was es am besten kann random bullshit produziert es denkt leute es denkt
By the way, warum benutzt das kein VRAM?
Warum benutzt das so gut wie kein RAM von der GPU?
Sollte das nicht ordentlich RAM benutzen?
Guck mal, es thinkt immer noch.
Habe ich das jetzt eigentlich mit Verbos aufgerufen, Leute?
Ja.
Guck mal, CPU Usage.
CPU-User zählt sich halbwegs in Grenzen.
Also das geht anscheinend gerade wirklich hauptsächlich über die GPU.
Alter.
Guck mal.
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel für ihn
500 Sätze, oder?
Ich glaube
Das müssen wir abbrechen
Ich glaube, das wird
Das wird zu viel
Mindestens 50 Sätze, okay
Ich glaube man kann
Paperless AI und Paperless GPT
sogar ganz gut zusammen verwenden.
Ich hab da mal ein Video drüber gesehen.
Ich hab's selbst noch nicht ausprobiert.
Think gleich low.
Naja.
Aber die Geschwindigkeit
finde ich, geht eigentlich echt ganz gut klar.
Das lassen wir uns jetzt mal testen.
Dann restarte ich
und gebe dem Ding mal
4 Gigramm. Mal gucken, ob es dann schneller ist.
Also ganz im Ernst,
keine Ahnung, was ChatGPT da macht.
ja für paypal das ist das mehr als schnell genug
ok einmal eine auge auf ipad und internet zweck scheinbar ist das zauber tx kühle längst 10 g und
retec treiber mögen keine riesigen cues bei 10 sollte standardwert bei 10.000 eingestellt
seiner fconfig text ok ok gute gute idee gucken wir jetzt gleich machen wir jetzt
kummer gleich jetzt schreibt er diesen mist okay
Okay, ChatGPT macht das, was es am besten kann, sinnlosen Shit produzieren.
Aber die 50 Sätze müsste er doch eigentlich schon fast hier durch haben.
Guck mal hier, der hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Der hat ja schon einen halben Roman geschrieben.
Ja, halber Roman über Twitch.
Okay, also ungefähr 19 Talkens.
Okay?
Ungefähr 19 Talkens die Sekunde.
Wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen kleiner auf 10 Sätze.
Okay, zack. Bis nächstes Mal.
Ja, und dann hier unten noch das da.
Mal copy-pasten.
Lockout.
und jetzt reboot
und mal ganz schnell
äh
ich hab das zugemacht, ich deb
mal ganz schnell ins
ins BIOS
das die geilen Leute sagen, ins BIOS
und da stellen wir jetzt ein
das ist für 4 GIG
ach komm, wir stellen einfach mal so viel ein wie geht
wir haben ja genug RAM
hier war das irgendwo oder auch nicht bock in bio gfx ich habe es gefunden
specify 16 gig die hälfte vom rahmen kriegt es jetzt einfach schneller schneller
kann es nicht mehr gehen
probier mir jetzt aus ob das jetzt deutlich schneller ist noch mal
zbm müssen wir auch noch installieren
da müsste jetzt eigentlich wieder gestartet haben dann probieren wir das mal mit der
q längst das ist eine gute idee also aber hier thema zack nv top nie was war das watch und dann
olama aber in zehn sätzen ok bisschen ein bisschen schneller jetzt muss er den kram erst mal wieder
laden also was ich mache ich mache keine full disk encryption von hut das mache ich nicht ich
mache zfs encryption von meinem mirror ssd mirror wo die vms und container drauf kommen und von den
festplatten dass das root system da ist nichts schützenswertes drauf da läuft wirklich nur
proxmox die backups kommen auf die entschlüsselte schlüssel in disks und die vm und alles kommt auf
die mirrors
guck mal der vram max macht lieber lux zfs zfs kann kein argon 2 idee ich werde
die fault encryption nehmen was ist das is 256 warum warum muss es argon 2 idee
sein
Chat, ist das jetzt bedeutend schneller?
Nicht wirklich.
Also das macht keinen Unterschied.
außer dass es jetzt in den in den wie rampen der grafik hat aber ganz ehrlich
eigentlich ist es ja auch irgendwie logisch dass es gar nicht so viel
unterschied ist weil der ram ja eh beides mal dass der gleiche ram ist
also dass das schmal das wird zwar wieder weg da will ich lieber das benutzbar machen also
für das System.
Ich stelle das wieder um. Und dann probieren wir
das mal mit der Q-Length.
Für die
Netzwerkkarten.
Ja.
Ich dachte, das verdammt zu spielen.
Setup.
Okay, wo war das Ding jetzt nochmal?
Haben die CBS, NBO?
Configuration, GPU-Configuration.
Uma Auto hatte ich.
Safe.
Ah, jetzt hat es wieder rumgebuckt.
Nice.
GG Eats.
Safe.
Okay.
Gut, also Chat, dann.
Was sollten wir hier ausprobieren?
Das da.
If Config gucken.
TXQ Length.
Von der Wartungsfenster, was?
von der Bridge oder von der Netzwerkkarte?
TXQ Length?
Ach, das kann man übrigens auch mal ausprobieren.
Die Netzwerkkarte direkt und nicht über diese Bridge.
Welche Tools das sind?
Hier unten das.
Moment, das kann ich dir gleich zeigen,
wenn es wieder da ist.
Das, was ich hier jetzt gerade benutzt habe, war
Rock'em's Me.
Das ist irgendein
AMD-Tool.
Man kann aber auch NV-Top benutzen.
Guck, NV-Top.
Guck mal hier.
NV-Top finde ich sogar noch ein bisschen schöner.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt hier sage, Ulama.
Jetzt muss das Ganze erstmal wieder laden
und sonst was.
Aber hier siehst du dann auch die
GPU-Memory-Usage und GPU-Auslastung.
gleich sehen gleich geht die auslastung hoch sobald sobald das anfängt was zu machen
auf lade jetzt mal das model hier kommen
auf auf
von der nick okay machen wir
was die default key der evasion von lux und zfs ist brauchen kann relativ das glaube ich nicht
Upgrade your looks key derivation function.
Aha.
Muss ich mir mal speichern und später mal durchlesen.
der artikel ist fast drei jahre alt genau ich auch gedacht da gibt es
ja katze
hier hast du hier siehst du sie gibt die gpu aus dass er so nv top finde ich persönlich
noch besser da guckt das ist wenn er hier was macht siehst du gleich blubb gpu auslastung
geht hoch warum auch immer es nv heißt unterstützt auch grafikkarten von amd
so
da war das immer dicht und jetzt war das mit der mit der netzwerkkarte ausprobieren also was war
das ist konflikt ok also ich konnte habe ich dann installiert aber ich bin auch ein ifconfig enjoyer
also was soll ich gucken sekunde leute ich soll gucken die ex-kuh längen
die ex-kuh lang 1000
1000 ok 1000 ist nicht gut oder das wert auslösen ip linkset hierfür die bridge
10.000
Äh, ja wie jetzt?
T-X-Q-Len...
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das muss ich jetzt mal checken.
Also wir machen erstmal noch mal zum Vergleich ein iPerf, okay?
Wie es jetzt ist.
Ja, hier.
Also die üblichen 8, irgendwas.
8,8.
ok und jetzt ip link bridge mach mal ein wert ok wer 3000
der fest appliziert oder 3000 ist garbage wo sie schreiben def
Okay, da kenne ich Dinger nicht.
Da muss man doch bestimmt noch was anderes dabei schreiben.
TXQLang, genau.
TXQLang 3000.
Nochmal.
Näh, kein Unterschied.
Ja, okay, Moment.
Ich muss das doch setzen auf die Bridge
und auf die Netzwerkkarte, oder?
Weil die Netzwerkkarte hat ja sowas auch.
Guck, hier ist die
TX4S3000. Ich setze das mal
auf die
auf NIC0 auch.
Näh.
Näh, das macht keinen Unterschied.
Das macht keinen Unterschied
Ein bisschen, ein ganz kleines bisschen
Unterschied macht es vielleicht
Aber mal 10.000
Ne, macht keinen Unterschied
Oder? Ne
wird das jetzt reset wenn ich das wieder wenn ich riebte ich kann es ja auch einfach einstellen
also das macht tatsächlich wenig unterschied ich würde sagen das macht gar keinen unterschied
Okay, ja da würde ich sagen, waren unsere
AI-Tests erfolgreich.
Es ist relativ schnell.
Muss man wirklich sagen.
Also damit kommt man
komplett, also ich finde,
das geht komplett klar.
19 Tokens die Sekunde.
Jaja, wir installieren jetzt Open Media Vault.
Das geht voll klar.
die Geschwindigkeit
okay also hier
Proxmox stellt
jetzt okay jetzt müssen wir uns
unserem ZFS widmen
also lass mal kurz in mich gehen ZFS stellt
ähm
ZFS
Create ZFS, ne wobei, wir machen das auf der Command Line, da traue ich dann eher.
Hier, Zpool, Create, Work, nennen wir den jetzt einfach.
Und da muss man jetzt die Weißes hinten dran packen.
Dev, Buy, Disk, Buy ID, was haben wir da?
Also die zwei will ich hier haben.
NVMe
Samsung SSD
Pro 990
Pro 1TB
und
2TB.
Okay. Den da und
den da.
Die Proxima
Scripts kenne ich, aber ich will nicht random
Zeug ausführen. Wie geht das nochmal?
Zpool Create Mirror.
Keine Ahnung. Zpool Create
Mirror.
Hallo?
Warum steht da nicht einfach ein Kommando drin?
Zpool create.
Hier.
Minus F minus O.
Zwölf.
Zwölf ist die Default A-Shift.
So.
Okay, also.
ZFS-Pool-Create.
Ja, und wo steht da jetzt...
Ach, Mirror. Mirror muss hier davor. Okay.
Mirror. Ja doch,
hab ich doch richtig gemacht.
Und jetzt kommt dann hinten
die da dran und die da.
Oh, und schon haben wir
unseren ZFS-Pool. ZFS-Pool
Status.
Da haben wir unsern ZFS-Pool.
Work heißt er.
Da ist er auch.
Okay.
Jetzt.
Encryption.
LZ4.
Einschalten.
ZWS Enable LZ4 Compression.
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie das Funks.
4 compression
oder dataset ganze ganze pool name work
zb lz 4 compression eingeschaltet das macht ja schon ein bisschen
langsamer noch encryption create encrypted zfs dataset
nein nicht wirklich aber fast wir wollen
der fs create minus encryption und das klingt okay und wir wollen key format passphrase den
den Rest wollen wir nicht.
Und der soll heißen
Work. Und das nennen wir Save.
Okay.
Passphrase 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Also das könnte man easy knacken,
habe ich jetzt gehört.
Aber ich habe eh dann
ein 24-stelliges Passwort
oder so.
ok jetzt haben wir hier unsere work safe da sind wir okay test seconds right ssd
boff weil sich aus dem kopf netz ja der thomas kern der weiß er weiß bescheid
weiß er nicht wie treibend ich will sie sequential ride haben
das müssen wir ein bisschen anpassen
I O Engine, PSYNC, I O Depth nix, NAM JOBS 1, File Name gleich, Blub Punkt Image, keine Ahnung,
Direct 0, wir wollen ja, ich darf schon Cachen, Block Size 128K ist für ZFS gut, Name juckt mich
nicht.
Sequence right?
Ne, okay.
Okay, ist einfach nur right.
Was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht?
Das stimmt doch so prinzipiell, oder was?
Äh.
I muss man noch angeben.
Wie lang der läuft?
Time.
Runtime.
Irgendwas verkehrt gemacht?
Das würde jetzt funzen, oder was?
Test.
Okay, das würde funzen.
Dann passen wir.
Runtime. 60 Sekunden.
nam jobs one reporting kann weg blog sei es das war schon okay für zfs direct 0
okay sei es ein gig und tests und test nur right erst mal
ich bin zu dumm dafür
Wie macht man das nochmal gescheit?
Der exitet sofort.
Ja, ähm...
Gute Frage!
Jo, Runtime!
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist nur den Buffer, den er verwendet zum Riten.
Der fängt dann immer wieder an, in dieses Gig zu schreien, wenn man es richtig macht.
Ich bin aber zu blöd dafür.
Ach, Time-Based muss man benutzen.
Das ist es, genau.
Time-Based.
Ja.
Okay, das flutscht, ja.
Ah, jetzt wird er langsamer.
Wahrscheinlich, weil der
SSD-Cache langsam...
Der Cache langsam voll ist.
Wir müssen das gerade nochmal abbrechen.
Weil wir müssen ja auch noch unseren Arc
und so Zeug setzen für ZFS.
Also, machen wir erstmal hier oben
das Ding. Hier oben haben wir
kurz unten die Auslastung. Gucken wir uns das an.
Das ist vollkommen
fein.
SSD-Temperaturen.
Install LM Sensors.
Sensors.
NVMe.
Crepe.
B3.
B4.
B5.
Okay, top
Watch
Okay, jetzt haben wir die
Auslastung, die Wärme von meinen
SSDs
Ich meine übrigens
Ich hab das Richtige getippt, aber das Falsche gesagt
Okay, nur die SSD-Temperaturen
sind aber vollkommen okay
Da kannst du nichts sagen
Ich meine, die haben ja auch einen Passivkühler
drauf
also hier oben schreibt da ganz ordentlich weg auf ssds das ist okay wir stellen jetzt
trotzdem noch mal ein fs set mit max linux na das ist ja einfach nur eine temperatur der in
der firma drin steht als hype das ist bullshit minus 273 grad ist halt einfach nur blödsinn was dahinter steht
genau das suche ich das suche ich was haben wir denn da aktuell 0 und next ok
also das da was ist das bei 2 gb bei 33 kommen okay da machen wir es mal so echo
ich spreche ich spreche es hier oben noch mal ab also mehr sieht der nach der
schwankt wir wobei kommt die minute lasse ich mal durchlaufen die zwei
minuten lassen wir durchlaufen dass ich ungefähr so eine größenordnung habe
wie denn die Übertragungsrate da so ist.
Aber das geht halbwegs klar.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen,
sobald der Cache aufgebraucht ist,
das geht ja relativ schnell,
bricht das halt ein bisschen ein.
Aber ich glaube, wir können es noch ein bisschen beschleunigen,
wenn wir den Arc ein bisschen größer machen.
Aber die Temperaturen passen, da muss man sich keine Gedanken machen, dass die SSDs zu warm werden.
Das ist okay.
Arc is no read?
Ne, ist der Arc nicht auch für...
Wie viel RAM der erste Mal weg buffert beim Riten?
Okay, 1400.
1400.
Wo stellt man dann ein, was der wegbuffert beim Schreiben?
Okay.
So, wir pappen das hier auf jeden Fall schon mal in Min rein,
dass der mindestens seine drei gig oder so macht 16 war was in 16
kann man das nicht vielleicht
das nicht vielleicht ausschreiben 16 die gebiet sind so dass es sind oder gebiet
geiler converter 16 ok perfekt und das da maximum 16 max
NFS Dirty Max Data, aha, aha, aha, aha. Was macht das? Oh ne, man copy-past es wieder kaputt. Ne, ist nicht kaputt. Was macht das?
Ist der ZFS Ride Throttle Dirty Space Limit? Once the limit is exceeded, new rides are delayed until space is freed.
Aha.
Default 10% of physical RAM.
Also es heißt
3,2 GIG
so quasi.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal, wie schnell der jetzt ist.
Äh.
Es muss doch was mit dem Arc zu tun haben, oder?
Guck mal, der ist jetzt gleich viel schneller.
Und der write nur, der liest nicht.
Ich meine, das passt jetzt ja auch komplett in den Rahmen und so alles.
Keine Ahnung.
ZFS ist, was das angeht, für mich immer noch ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln.
hast du eine usv also jetzt gerade nicht jetzt steht es auf dem tisch aber normalerweise schon
okay dann müssen wir das mal was cooles kommen wir schreiben jetzt einfach mal
sei es was was definitiv nicht in ram passt 400 gig
da schon ist es schon ist es ein bisschen kleiner
er geht es auch gleich geht es auch gleich runter mit der geschwindigkeit
Aber ist trotzdem ein bisschen schneller.
Okay, was ist denn jetzt hier?
ZFS Dirty.
Aber 3G ist ja auch eigentlich erst einmal okay.
Es gibt ein ZFS Optimierungsskript.
So, so.
Und er will das Limit ist überwiesen, neue Reise sind gedelayt.
Nee, das will ich ja nicht.
Wie viel RAM ist jetzt in use?
Doch, der benutzt den RAM jetzt.
Also irgendwas hat das mit diesem Arc-Dings auch zu tun.
Okay, whatever.
Das werden wir jetzt mal...
ETC Mod Probe...
ZFS, werden wir das mal reinschreiben.
min und das andere zfs arg max gleich und da müssen wir jetzt noch update init ramfs
minus A. Minus U
glaube ich machen.
Dass er das Z, das checkt.
DVI, Boot.
Ne.
Okay.
So, jetzt sollte das eigentlich gesetzt sein.
Gut, das heißt, wir kriegen
bei verschlüsselten ZFS, kriegen wir
ungefähr, also bei einem
miroten
encrypten komprimierten zfs auf die ssds kriegen wir ungefähr 1300 mebibytes also
hier 1400 megabytes pro sekunde hin das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig geil aber das
ist normaler speed bei ssd bei nvme ssds wenn er cashvoll ist
einfach sync disablen will ich das mal ausprobieren was da der unterschied ist
zfs set was jetzt sync und jetzt auf oder was auf
Work, save
Ne, must be disabled
Ich disable das mal
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt so eine gute Idee ist
Aber mal gucken, was der Unterschied ist
Okay
Das flutscht
Das flutscht schon schneller
Aber das werde ich nicht hören
Das hat garantiert irgendeinen Nachteil
Ach nee, guck mal, sobald der Ramm voll ist, geht's auch runter.
Gar kein so großer Unterschied mehr.
Machen wir lieber wieder Standard.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so schnell, aber...
...hat bestimmt andere Probleme weniger.
Gut also das ist von der Geschwindigkeit her vollkommen okay das kann man so lassen jetzt next vm
Ich muss erst mal den Debian runterladen nee chat muss ich nicht
alter
Nee Moment ich will gar kein Debian ich bin ja blöd ich will ein Open Media Vault
Open Media Vault ist doch bestimmt in netboot xyz drinne oder nicht
dann war jetzt px champ aber vorher muss ich erst mal noch historisch storage anlegen also
rechnen wir das mal ab den storage müssen wir jetzt hinzufügen das geht hier irgendwo discs
Nee, hier geht das. Storage? Seht ihr irgendwo Storage? Здесь? Здесь?
Здесь? Здесь? Здесь? Здесь? Здесь?
Здесь?
ja so hat er fest work safe die in das ja hier safe
im provisioning blogs das enable blubb nots ich habe nur einen ort der es für
disk images und container ja wohl der hier der ist weder für disk images und
container den werden wir nicht verwenden und der hier der storage ist am ende bis
nippert nicht für import iso images container backups container templates ja
das ist okay das ist ja nicht schützenswert dass letztendlich okay so
machen wir das und jetzt erstellen wir mal eine vm und schauen wir mal ob das
funktioniert. Wo ist der Knopf nochmal? Also ich muss erstmal hier... ne.
Ach da! Ist extra in blau, dass man es besser sieht.
Create4M. Das Ding heißt Open Media Vault. Advanced natürlich immer Advanced
bei uns hier startet gut nach so was ich muss mir auch noch irgendwas bauen dass ich dann denke die
platten zu anlocken nach dem reboot us do not use any media qmo agent für die für die platte an sich
ist das okay aber wir wollen ja dann meine ssd in form ssd raid 1 durchreichen das ist
nur zum system installieren backup ja ssd emulation auch okay das kann auch okay cpu
socke okay kriegt man fünf kerne würde ich sagen ja ist okay und 4096 sollte für sammler kram
reichen network kriegt ja das ist okay wird ein firm finish so jetzt müssen wir noch ein
paar sachen durchreichen wobei wir installieren erst wir installieren erst mal open media volt
open media volt muss man noch irgendwas an der hardware drehen das können wir entfernen das
erinnert maschinen dings so passt
die ssd sein omb ich will auf den ssds will ich also überlegt habe ich ein
freundes das erste der ssd mir wird für container und vms deswegen musste ein
proxmox aber ich benutze den auch als cash für mein nass weil ich brauche
davon wahrscheinlich guckt oder so dann habe ich alle container und vms drauf
die ich brauche so viele wird das ja nicht vor allem braucht es hat viel
speicher und lassen 150 gig sein
Deswegen muss das durchgereicht werden.
Jetzt installieren wir erstmal Open Media Vault.
Konsole.
PXE Champ.
Ist am starten.
Prog.
Können wir das hier fullscreenen?
Gescheit.
Oma.
Äh.
Warum hat das gerade neu gestartet?
Was? No more devices?
Hä?
Was?
Äh...
Chat, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Moment, guckt mal, der startet
das Falsche.
Der startet das
Falsche. Der soll...
Der startet das Falsche.
Der lädt Budi-EPX-E,
das ist falsch das ist mein px ist aber da macht komische dinger ich sag's euch
da macht das stimmt was nicht dass man prinzipiell gucken ob es noch
funktioniert hat mal kurz px e boot in der form starten glaube ich weiß woran
es liegt bios
ich habe für bios und uefi drin ich glaube ich glaube man px meinen dhcp
Proxy erkennt das nicht richtig. Guck hier.
Hier ist es nämlich alles noch da. Hier funzt das.
Wenn auch irgendwie grad ein bisschen
komisch, aber es funzt.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran.
Oh, vor allem
wir backen. Jetzt bricht es wieder nicht ab.
So, jetzt bricht es ab.
Gut.
Ne, ne, das funzt schon.
Das liegt daran.
Ich weiß aber noch nicht so genau,
wie ich es fixen soll. Das liegt
daran, dass etc.
dns-mask-conf
Hier, das matcht nicht richtig
Was gibt es da für Sachen, die man
Das matcht nicht richtig hier
x86 PC
Das ist das Problem, das matcht nicht richtig
Ähm
Was gibt's denn da sonst noch alles?
Weil er liefert eindeutig das Falsche aus.
Der liefert...
Ah, du meinst, der versucht schon
E-PXE zu booten und deswegen
geht das nicht? Meinst du das?
Ach so,
der versucht direkt schon per E...
Ach so.
Okay, dann ist das in der Tat ein Problem.
weil in meinem ipx das ist custom kompiliert und
das sind optionen drin die das standard ipx ähnlich kann
kann man das irgendwie ausschalten
Firewall machen wir auch mal aus. Der soll nur normales PXE Boot machen. Muss man da vielleicht in der VM ins BIOS?
und troll control alt
legacy option rom das gut
wieder startet gleich pxe
Okay, das ist in der Tat doof.
Weil ich habe in meinem, wie gesagt,
in meinem IPXE Sachen drin, die das
normale
Box, Mox, Disable,
IPXE.
Okay, ich glaube, ich weiß, was wir machen müssen.
Wir müssen da einen
If reinmachen wahrscheinlich
Hier, boot IPXE
Ja
Ähm
Kann man?
Oh, fuck, das will ich jetzt eigentlich nicht
Debuggen, wir müssten dem hier sagen
Der soll einen IPXE von woanders
Booten
Chain
IPXE Chain
Chainload.
Das da.
Genau.
Irgendwie sowas.
Sowas in der Richtung brauchen wir.
Der soll...
Wenn... Oh, das ist natürlich wieder eklig.
Wenn es das hier nicht gibt...
Wenn es das hier nicht gibt,
soll der umstellen.
Dann soll der Chain booten.
aber von wo
srv tfdp
ja hier ist hier liegt ja mal hier liegt ja mein
Oh fuck.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt funzt.
Okay, das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Das dauert mir zu lang.
wir stellen das einfach um das muss ich mir dann nachher mal irgendwie überlegen
Bei der VM unter Option einfach Boot Order die Netzwerkkarte deaktivieren.
Ja, das will ich ja nicht.
Okay.
Wir stellen es mal kurz um.
Hardstop.
Bam.
Hardware Options.
Steht hier irgendwas drin?
Ähm.
Boot Order. Na, Boot Order.
Juckt mich nicht.
Okay, wir stellen mal kurz um, dass das eine
eine EFI-basierte
Kiste ist. Wo stellt man denn
den bios typ um bios hier
red ich muss eine e4 okay das will ich eigentlich okay scheiß drauf leute
schaaf net boot xyz iso iso
netboot xyz iso perfekt copy link so wie bringt man das jetzt in proxmox rein hier irgendwie
ne iso images download vom url dahin jetzt netboot xyz runterladen genau download so
jetzt können wir sagen cd jetzt muss ich das doch machen storage local iso netboot xyz jawohl
ok start
jetzt sollte okay oder auch nicht
Ist denn jetzt das CD-Laufwerk verbunden oder nicht?
Warum ist das hier ausgegraut?
Hä?
Äh
Warum ist das grau?
Was?
Use den Haken?
was für ein haken wo
es hat funktioniert es hat jetzt irgendwie aus irgendwelchen gründen doch
gebootet
okay
also wir müssen jetzt network installs wahrscheinlich open media wall ist es hier
drin moment ist auch media ball vielleicht gar nicht in ist das gar nicht in netboot xyz trainer
moment
Das ist da gar nicht drin.
Ach so.
Ach, das ist...
Okay.
Open Media Vault Download.
Da laden wir es halt so runter.
Meinetwegen.
ok ob die wo müssen denn die isos überhaupt hin dass der die findet
box mox wehrer iso files und dass das weg hätten kann
war live vz template iso war live vz es template iso ok wie geht
der fahrt was das das ist ja schon fast telekom period geschwindigkeit
Das ist ja nix.
Okay, abbrechen.
Oh, Media Walls.
So, was haben wir dafür?
Okay, das geht schneller.
Nice. Copy, download, link.
Haben wir irgendein anderes erwischt?
Soll mir recht sein. Irgendeins, was schneller geht.
Einfach so lange klicken,
bis es funktioniert.
Oh ne, es wird langsamer.
Nein, nicht langsamer werden.
Nicht langsamer werden.
Nein, nicht, nicht, slow down.
Werd einfach fertig.
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Das Ding geht...
Fuck, Mann.
Das schläft jetzt wieder ein und es wird nicht fertig.
Ich seh's schon kommen.
Gleich hängt er bei 140 Kilobit oder so.
Vielleicht geht es ja zwischendurch über die Telekom.
Ja, das kann sein.
Der Jibaded uns.
Der ist jetzt seit 40 Sekunden schon bei 40 Sekunden.
Rage.
Hyperbrake.
Wenn ich das in der UI mache,
hätte er jetzt langsam runtergeladen
und ich hätte überhaupt nichts gesehen.
Außerdem habe ich Netboot eben schon über das UI gemacht.
So.
Aber WGET ist einfach besser.
Da sieht man wenigstens was.
Okay.
MV Open Media Vault
zu Open Media Vault
ISO.
Ja, aber du hast
nichts gesehen, wie schnell es ist.
Was natürlich sagt.
Dann weißt du nämlich nicht, ob er gleich fertig ist oder ewig braucht.
Okay, stopp.
Start.
Open Media Vault.
Okay, da startet wieder PXE.
Da muss der PXE erstmal abkacken,
dass er jetzt...
Ja, Install.
Können wir Fullscreen machen?
Ja.
Okay, Language, Englisch.
Territory, Europe, Germany.
Ja.
German Keyboard.
Tutututu.
Jetzt installieren wir erst einmal Open Media Vault und gucken.
Achso, ich sollte vielleicht mal auf den richtigen Monitor gucken.
Hostname Open Media World, sehr gut.
Domain Internal, auch gut.
Rootpasswort 123456789.
123456789.
Top Secret Passwörter heute, Leute.
Wie er rät keiner.
Best Practice Passwörter.
Ja doch, mein Ansatz bei Passwörtern ist immer,
wenn viele Leute das gleiche Passwort nutzen,
dann ist das ja quasi etabliert.
Und so viele Leute können sich ja nicht irren, dass es ein schlechtes Passwort ist.
Deswegen setze ich eben auf diese Passwörter.
Das ist so oft erprobt worden, dieses Passwort.
Das kann nicht schlecht sein.
Kappa HD.
Zettel am Monitor ist nicht verkehrt.
Ne, habe ich ja letztens mich auch schon mal lang drüber ausgelassen.
reboot
mal gucken was wir für eine ip kriegen
deswegen kauft auch jeder vom marktführer genauso jetzt aus 21 41 12 2.141
1.
Admin Open Media Vault,
wenn ich nicht ganz verkehrt liege.
Nein.
Hab ich vertippt?
Ich hab mich vertippt.
Okay, Dashboard
is not yet configured.
Ja, dann halt nicht.
So, als erstes stellen wir jetzt mal
eine gescheite Adresse ein, weil sonst
finde ich das Ding nachher nicht.
Und wir machen hier mal den Dark...
Uh, mein Auge, mein Auge, Moment, das kann man doch irgendwie
umstellen hier.
Close, close call.
Schaust du noch ein paar Proxmox
Templates auf eine fertige Variante von
Open Media?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich installiere
das Lieder. Ich kann mal gucken.
Wo soll ich gucken? Hier? Oder was?
Das ist
aber eine VM. Und keine
und keinen Container.
Gibt's auch nicht.
Okay, also DHCP, nein, Static.
1 und 2, 1, 6, 8, 2 Punkte, machen wir jetzt 5, 2.
Ne, da musst du bestimmt 2, 5, 5, 2, 5, Punkt 0 hinschreiben.
Gateway, äh, 50.
Und DNS-Server, 50, save.
so zack zack jetzt müssten wir da eigentlich schon drauf kommen
admin admin open media world not now das immer wieder
weiß dass das dashboard not konfiguriert wurde ok also das haben wir jetzt dann
gehen wir da mal per SSH drauf.
SSH.
52.
Root allerdings diesmal.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9.
So, okay. Also
Open Media Vault. Wir wollen jetzt ein Samba
Share machen auf mein ZFS.
Und mein Encrypted Komprimiertes ZFS.
Das heißt, ich muss das erstmal durchreichen
überhaupt an Open Media Vault.
Wir machen mal
noch eine Sache hier vorher.
diesen test hier aber nicht mit 400 gig sondern mit einem gig machen wir mal hier auf die platte
von open media wollte mal gucken was installiert was passiert update zu leben was ihr habt install
T-Mux, Hardtop,
ähm,
jo.
Geht sehr zackig.
Also, Abt ist richtig
gut geworden mittlerweile. Früher war das lahm.
Das Ganze wird nur noch von alten
Jam-Versionen getoppt.
Das ist langsam, Leute.
Red Hat Package Manager. Mittlerweile
unter neueren Red Hat Versionen geht das auch.
Aber ohne Scheiß, Jam
früher, das war echt Ausgeburt der Hölle.
Oh ja.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Du meinst Gig anstelle von Gigabyte?
Kennst du?
Ich benutze das eigentlich fast immer.
Aber ich bin ja auch Boomer, da ist das okay.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir die Disk irgendwie durchreichen.
Wie funsten das jetzt?
Hardware?
Add?
Wird IOFS?
Genau, was? Mapping.
Äh.
Hä?
Directory Mappings can be managed
under datacenter directory mappings.
Hier bestimmt, hä?
Ne, Jammer auf den neuen Systemen ist auch okay.
Ich glaube, Jammer ist ja mittlerweile wahrscheinlich auch nur noch ein Link auf DNF.
Vermutlich.
ist aber auch viel haben das alles installiert hat immer und so das war
richtig abpacken ach data center da steht ja sogar date
kann man so man
keine ahnung cash aber wirk safe
Oder machen wir da drin vielleicht nochmal
Machen wir da drin vielleicht nochmal
Einen Ordner
Äh, weil dann ist das ganze Mist hier
Äh, mkdir
omv, okay, so
Slash omv
O-o-m-v, oh alter
Create
Hier hin
Add
wird da jo fs mapping cash extended rcl geduld und das lasse aber cash default cash never ganz
ehrlich müssen wir noch mehr cashen wir stellen wir auf never oder kommt scheiße wir lassen wir
die fault oder probieren können es mal ausprobieren weil wir müssen ja nicht auf 50 ebene den kram
cashen okay es wurde jetzt noch nicht verbunden
dazu muss ich das erst mal power offen power offen geiles wort aller power oft
ja auch muss das power offen
start
Englisch
Ganz schlimm, ne
Also bei mir besonders schlimm
Aber Leute, die absichtlich
Die Sachen auf, wisst ihr was richtig
Boomer cringe ist, wo wir es gerade
Davon haben
Die Leute, die sagen
Mini weich winddoof
Oh, das ist so cringe
Alter, das tut mir richtig weh beim aussprechen
Mini-Weich-Window,
Alter.
Cringe das nicht auch bei euch,
wenn ihr das hört?
Da zieht sich bei mir alles zusammen.
Das ist so schlimm.
Das sagen jetzt wirklich nur 60 Plus,
Alter.
Microsoft Windows.
Ach, winzig-weich.
Nicht mini-weich.
das ist ja winzig weich window winzig weich du hast recht micro weiß winzig
weich nicht mini weich ja winzig weich window
das ist das schlimm
okay maun minus t das war jetzt glaube ich einfach wird wird als alter was für
drei milliarden sachen kann ich da bitte schön angeben
Moment, wie mountet man das jetzt?
Hier, mit
Cache, glaube ich, es muss Cache heißen
Cache
nach
MNT, ha, Kunst
Ja, MNT
Okay, es ist der Kran geworden.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt nochmal den Fio-Test drauf, wie schnell das jetzt hier auf die Platte schreibt von der VM auf dem Host.
Bei der Gelegenheit.
Ups.
Kartopf.
Geht doch klar.
Guck mal hier, der ist auch nicht wirklich viel langsamer, als wenn der auf dem Host schreibt.
da ist so in dem dreh zu 1,21,3 gig pro sekunde
doch okay
ja doch für das geht das geht in ordnung jetzt würde ich noch mal power off machen gerade moment
wir machen jetzt mal was anderes wir nehmen jetzt war dass das netzwerk das nicht vergessen zu
mountain wir nehmen jetzt mal den befehl und vorher machen wir noch ein ch mod 777 auf mnt
nur für den fall der fälle dass das spiel funktioniert wir gehen jetzt mal
hier hin und richten den kontraband reboot dass er das jedes mal mounted
sonst vergesse ich das nämlich so wir schalten das jetzt noch mal aus und
schalten den cash ab und gucken ob es dann irgendwie bedeutend langsamer ist
oder nicht
kann man das nicht in die fs tab schreiben doch wobei kann man nicht weil
die fs tab glaube ich von media world generiert wird
Oh, jetzt ist der Cache...
Oh, ich kann nur...
Oh, stopp.
Ich habe das Wichtigste vergessen.
Ich wollte eigentlich hier Cache auf Never stellen.
Okay.
So, und jetzt kann man wieder starten.
Gut.
Connecten.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
Und hat er jetzt gemountet?
Ja, hat er, sehr gut
Excellent
So, und nun gehen wir hier hin
Muss uns natürlich nochmal einloggen
Admin, Open Media Vault
Save, wir speichern es jetzt
Okay
Und jetzt testen wir gerade noch einmal
Wie schnell das jetzt ist
Ob es einen Unterschied macht
Moment, Moment, ich bin ja auch dumm
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee
Nicht 1 Gig
400 Gig
Dass er nicht in Cash schreibt
ganz ehrlich der ist ziemlich genauso schnell wie auf dem host eigentlich gar
keinen unterschied verbraucht zwar ordentlich cpu und sowas aber man darf
nicht vergessen der schreibt auch gerade mit 1,4 gb die sekunde
Äh, das ist okay.
Damit kann ich leben.
Dass es mehr als 10 Gig Netzwerk hergibt.
Das reicht.
Ähm, Sternchen.
Bäm.
Okay, also.
Dann richten wir dafür doch jetzt mal einen Samba-Share ein.
Ach, komm.
Du darfst nicht.
Du darfst vorher nochmal Package-Updates machen.
Passt das Max...
Äh, passt das Max...
Max, passt das Max in einen 10-Zoll-Rack?
Hm.
Hm...
Ich würde sagen, ja, gerade so.
Aber gucken wir mal nach.
Warte mal, ich mess mal.
Ich mess mal kurz aus.
Wenn ich wüsste, wo ich mein Maßband hab.
Okay, wir messen es nicht aus, weil ich hab keine Ahnung, wo ich mein...
Meta-Mas-Ding hin habe.
Hm.
Weiß ich gerade nicht, wo ich den hab.
Sonst hätte ich mal kurz gemessen.
Den habe ich irgendwo hingeschmissen und finde ihn jetzt gerade nicht mehr.
Wartet mal, ich gucke mal, ob vielleicht ist er hier drin.
Ne.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ah, ich hab ihn.
Ich hab ihn.
Also, das Ding ist...
Moment.
Reit.
20.
20 Zentimeter.
Das passt in einen 10-Inch-Rack.
10 Inch.
Ein Inch ist was?
2, irgendwas Zentimeter?
2,21 cm, 2,51 cm, 2,54 cm, dann passt es.
Dann passt es.
Das ist 20, das ist ganz knapp 19,9 würde ich sagen.
Ja, Zentimeter ist das...
Ist das hier breit?
Und hoch, können wir auch mal gucken, das ist jetzt nicht so wirklich relevant dafür, aber gucken wir mal.
hoch ist es
ungefähr auch 20
Zentimeter. Also es ist
sehr quadratisch.
Aber nach hinten hin könntest du vielleicht
ein bisschen Probleme kriegen. Lass mal gucken.
Tiefe ist 24,5.
Also ich würde sagen,
ich würde sagen,
das passt in einen 10 Zoll Rack rein.
Du kannst es aber halt
nur auf den Boden stellen, weil da ist halt mit Rack
nix könnte mir allerdings vorstellen dass es eventuell findige leute gibt die da irgendwie
einen rack mount für konstruieren stelle ich mir schwierig vor hat vorne nix wurde großartig
daran angehen könnte es das ganze anmachen können dran machen können ich könnte mir vorstellen finde
die leute machen finden da vielleicht was ansonsten stellt es einfach auf eine platte im
rack oder auf dem boden
so also jetzt war ein sammler einstellen alles klar gut wie machen wir das jetzt
man muss erst einmal hier hin shared folders genau zack selekte da gab es ein
plugin für plugin irgendwas mit root
share root fs ja weil er denkt das ist die die route platte was er blödsinn ist
damit erkennt halt mein vm-mount nicht
Du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du
Relative Path
MNT
Slash
Wollen wir da noch einen Folder drin anlegen?
Ja, wir legen noch einen Folder
vorbei
Data
Bester Name immer
So
Das...
Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Okay, das muss man angeben.
Ist auch egal.
Äh, everyone.
Darf da drauf schreiben.
Okay, whatever.
Was auch immer das war.
Ich hoffe, es hat jetzt trotzdem funktioniert.
Ja, da ist es doch.
Da ist es doch.
Okay, Shared Folder.
Und jetzt müssen wir doch ein Samba Shared raus machen.
Share.
Browsable.
Bla, bla, bla.
Ja, wunderbar.
Achso, und einen User brauchen wir natürlich noch.
Ein User. User. Create.
Keine Ahnung. Max.
Passwort. 123456.
123456. Top Secret.
Shell brauchen wir nicht. Select Groups.
Samba.
Geht's nämlich nicht.
Save.
Und jetzt Apply.
So, und wenn wir das jetzt richtig gemacht haben, dann sollten wir unter...
...2.168, 2.25...
...max, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
...einen Ordner haben. Share.
So, jetzt brauche ich mal irgendwas zum Übertragen.
Wo hab ich denn meine VMs liegen?
So ein VM-Image oder so ist vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt zum...
Machen wir hier unten noch einmal...
Machen wir hier auch einen Hardtop drinnen an?
Also, wo haben wir es denn hier?
Documents.
Virtual Machines.
Moment.
Theme.
VMs.
Da.
Guck mal hier.
Hier haben wir doch ein großes File.
Hier.
261 Gig.
Zack.
Mal gucken, wie schnell er ist.
Öh.
Was ist das?
Warum ist der so lahm?
Das ist ja abfuck langsam.
Ah.
Weil.
Weil Samba Client 100% CPU last?
Wir brauchen keine...
Samba Signing.
Was für ein Ding.
Was ist Samba Signing?
Chatge?
Oder besser gesagt Target was was wie Samba Signing?
Das Samba Config ist mein Endgegner.
Da checke ich immer nichts.
Ist Samba Single Threaded?
Ich dachte eigentlich nicht.
Sigen? Sigen? Sigen? Samba Signing, was ist das?
Disable Signing?
Das hast du von der KI generieren lassen, ne?
Samba Signing sorgt dafür, dass er sich zu jeder Smb, das habe ich auch gerade gelesen im Internet, ja
Meinst du?
Ich habe eine Idee, woran das liegen könnte.
Mal gucken, ob ich recht habe.
Zum Testen kann man es mal ausmachen.
Wo gebe ich denn hier Samba-Options an?
Ich habe eine Idee, woran das liegt.
Aber erstmal probieren wir das hier aus.
Kann man gar nicht.
Man kann aber hier unten extra Options reinschreiben.
Okay, so.
Schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt schneller ist.
Ein bisschen, nicht wirklich.
Also, ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt, Chat.
Jetzt machen wir mal hier für den High-IQ-Chat.
Habt ihr auch eine Idee, woran das liegen könnte?
Wer zuerst das richtige
Gerät oder weiß
Kriegt einen Sub gegiftet von mir
NFS CPU Host
AES CPU Dings, richtig das denke ich auch
AES
Take Viagra Die Hard
Das denke ich auch
Genau das denke ich auch
Der will
Der hat aus irgendwelchen Kunden
Obwohl das hier
da steht. Guckt mal.
Das steht da.
Irgendwo habe ich das gerade gesehen.
Prozessor. Guckt, da steht
AES.
Aber ich
habe das blöde Gefühl, hier ist
keine Hardware Encryption durchgelassen.
Und wenn
ich das richtig im Kopf habe, man kann
das. Wir machen mal folgendes.
Wir stellen die Host CPU ein.
Und reichen AES durch.
Wir machen beides jetzt.
Zack.
Start.
Das verdammte Spiel.
Ist er wieder da?
Noch nicht.
Okay, so, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Ah.
Äh.
Warum ist denn das so langsam?
Warum ist das so langsam?
Moment mal.
ab install
Iperf 3 moment
Iperf 3 minus c
warum ist das in der vm in den xudp an warum ist das in der vm nur halb so schnell wie auf
dem host wie geht denn das serviert was soll ich in die sambal konf schreiben aber das hat
ja nichts mit das ammerkopf zu tun network device schau mal ob die
realtec auch srv kann kann sie nicht schon nachgeguckt das ist eigentlich ok
so du morgen danke schön für den sap o7 pok
warum ist das so lahm es ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das große ausgelastet oder so
mach mal zwischen vm und sprox muss ich ja nicht ich habe hier unten den den speed test
das liegt eindeutig an der netzwerk bridge oder an der an irgendwas mit
virtualisieren okay okay ich habe die chat chat pass auf idee
multi q
ok
multi q hier
schauen wir mal
ich bin dafür wir rebooten mal und gucken ob es dann immer noch so ist man glaubt gar nicht wie
oft reboot einfach die sachen fix oder
Ja, kann mal passieren.
Deswegen habe ich früher immer
Molligard installiert.
Falls es noch jemand... Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Das war immer äußerst praktisch.
Wartet mal.
Up install.
Das habe ich früher immer installiert, weil wenn ich jetzt sage Power Off, dann fragt er, bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass du ausschalten willst?
Dann musst du sagen, ja, Open Media Vault musst du eintippen.
Das fand ich immer ganz nützlich.
Das installieren wir hier jetzt auch mal, dass ich nicht mein Nassausfall runterfahre.
Wobei auf dem Nass ist wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee zu installieren.
Naja.
Welches Nass? Das ist ein Minisforum N5R.
Oder auch Luft, wie die das auf der deutschen Webseite nennen.
Schlechte
Das chinesische Ministerium für Webseiten
Translation hat es ein bisschen verkackt
N5 Luft
AI, natürlich
Weil AI überall hin muss, hat mit AI aber gar nichts zu tun
So, also IPR
Ist es immer noch so kacke?
Warum? Warum ist das so schlecht?
Okay, Chat, ich habe eine Idee
Wo ist unsere KVM?
Hier.
The Root.
Modprobe.
Minus R.
Bam.
Modprobe.
Jawohl.
IP-Link
up?
Cannot find? Was?
Oh!
Was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht?
Warum findet er jetzt die Netzwerkkarte nicht mehr?
Warum finde ich jetzt die Netzwerkkarte?
Was? 1, 9.
1, 6, 9?
aber das findet moment ich will ich will das anlohnen
Ah ja, okay, jetzt geht's.
Da ist die Netzwerkkarte wieder.
Äh, minus I.
Jetzt hat's den Treiber.
Äh, Brüder, CTL,
Add, ja, gut.
Jetzt sollte es eigentlich hier wieder gehen.
Gleich, irgendwann.
Oder auch nicht.
Ab.
Ah jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt geht's wieder. Ja wunderbar. Okay jetzt mal hier ausprobieren
Easy! Och nee oder?
Ja das ist ja mal absoluter Hardcore Suck. Der Netzwerktreiber im Kernel suckt.
Da muss ich jetzt auch ein paar Kernel Versions Updates abwarten anscheinend.
Es ist aber, das ist aber richtig mies.
Das ist aber schon ziemlich, ziemlich räudig, ne?
Ja, das sind billige 10-Gig-Karte.
Das stimmt, aber die ist on-board.
Ich kann da nichts machen.
Wisst ihr was?
Vielleicht ist es doch an der Zeit, mir eine Intel 10-Gig zu kaufen für einen PC-Express-Slot.
Ne, ich habe einen PC-Express-Slot drin.
ich kann einfach eine einbauen oder selbst ändern was soll ich ändern
in boxbox sammler installiert du kannst die meldungs karte per pc
Netzwerk im Kernel.
Ja klar.
Ich werde Kernelentwickler.
Easy.
Ähm.
Ne, ich glaube, ich besorg mir vielleicht wirklich so eine...
Doch, doch, ich glaube, ich besorg mir so eine Intel-Netzwerkkarte.
Und benutze die dann dafür.
SFV Plus braucht ja allgemein weniger Strom.
Vielleicht nimmt sich das dann so plus minus nix.
Dafür habe ich dann zwei Ports.
Eine mit sehr guter Treiberunterstützung unter Linux und SRIOV.
Immer noch PXE mit Mellanox-Karte.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Mellanox-Karte habe ich wieder rausgebaut.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Wir rebooten jetzt und gucken, wie es dann aussieht.
Moment, den will ich ja nicht rebooten.
Apt install übrigens QEMU.
Guest Agent.
der wird hier installiert systemctl enable qemu west agent minus minus lau ok
wir schalten ihn mal aus und dann wieder ein und gucken ob es dann funktioniert bei der
gelegenheit kann ich jetzt auch mal gucken angeblich hat die netzwerkkarte
einen Bug. Die lädt nicht
korrekt.
Wenn man
nicht Power weg macht davon.
Okay, muss ich nicht enablen.
Na gut, schadet aber auch nichts, oder?
Okay, ich mach wieder an.
Schauen wir mal kurz was.
R8127
Virtualization
Performance
Backport
Jetzt soll ich vielleicht noch RTL direkt suchen.
FoxMox, slower network speed in 4Ms.
Vor einer Woche.
Real Tech Driver is to blame.
Okay, wir müssen noch ein paar Kernel-Versionen warten.
Ja, wir müssen noch ein paar Kernel-Versionen warten, bis das Ding richtig gut läuft.
Das habe ich schon gesagt, Coemo.
Okay, das labert einfach wieder irgendwas
Very new budget unstable drivers.
Schweine.
Okay, die AI labert richtigen Bullshit wieder.
Professional Create, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ach, das habe ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert hier.
Bidirectional.
Das war anscheinend mal noch schlechter.
Ja, mit dem alternativen Treiber ist ja auch alles zackig.
Mit dem alternativen Treiber ist ja auch alles okay.
Jetzt hat er halt wieder den vom Kernel.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, wie es jetzt ist nach dem Reboot.
Ah, das geht jetzt nicht.
Ich muss...
Mein ZFS ist ja nicht geladen.
Warte mal.
ZFS mount-l
Work
Save
Okay
Ich mach mir mal, falls ich noch mehr
So was hier im Startpunkt SH oder sowas
In Punkt Bash
Ja
Okay
So, jetzt startet es auch
Gehen wir hier oben nochmal drauf
iPerf
Fuck
Das ist einfach langsam mit dem Treiber im Kernel
Ja, das ist ja mega mies
Dann hau das Original drauf
Hau das auf die Blacklist
Ja, das dumme ist, dass ich mir da schon Gedanken mache
Wie ist das bei Kernel-Updates und allem möglichen
Ja, also
Na gut, das ist ja ein
DKMS-Status.
DKMS.
Das ist kein DKMS.
Das wird also nicht jedes Mal neu gebaut.
Das muss ich quasi jedes Mal,
wenn der Kernel geupdatet wird,
muss ich diesen ganzen Mist
selbst neu kompilieren.
Und da habe ich aber Bock drauf.
Welchen Kernel ich habe?
An A-A.
16, 17, 9
DKMS selbst machen
für den Treiber
ja wie oft machst du ein Kernelupdate? Alle paar Wochen?
kommt eine neue meiner Version
ich habe keine Ahnung
wie man DKMS für den Treiber macht
absolut kein bloß ein Schimmer
wir können ja mal kurz gucken
R8127
DKMS, ob es das schon gibt irgendwo
aha
Aha.
guck mal hier es gibt von openwrt
gibt es auch
Am ersten august ja da ungefähr von der wahl real tech
Guckt mal ungefähr von dem hier real tech
doch das richtige nochmal ungefähr von hier ist das ja auch das ist vom ersten vom 30 7 und das
jetzt von erst nacht also ich gehe mal stark von aus dass das was sie hier haben ob wir t stellts
Ich habe seriously keinen blassen Schimmer, wie DKMS funktioniert.
Also zumindest können wir das Archie-Nux-Ding schon mal nett für unseren Debian verwenden.
Für unseren Proxmox.
Lass uns mal was schauen.
Haben wir vielleicht Realtec?
Haben wir da vielleicht irgendwas im...
Hier drinnen?
Hier haben wir Realtec.
R81.
Okay, ne.
okay na geil wir haben den 8125 und in 8168 aber in 8127 haben wir nett
das ist das ist das ist das ist enorm paint champ dass das so langsam ist
also es liegt ja auch eindeutig am treiber also weil mit dem anderen geht habe ich
gut jetzt noch mal was checken ob es vielleicht mit einem hot reboot irgendwie tut
Ebian.
Ne, für Ebian gibt es das nicht.
Boah, ist das ein... also ganz ehrlich...
Ganz ehrlich, Netzwerkkarte ist so schon ein krasser Painschamp die letzten zwei Tage über.
Muss ich mal vorstellen.
Gestern mit der 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte übelst rumgekämpft und abgekotzt.
Und heute festgestellt, dass mit dem offiziellen Linux-Driven...
Chat, ich hab ne Idee.
Gibt es für Proxmox Kernel 6.19 schon?
Proxmo... Ah, guck mal.
Gucke mal da.
Das ist vielleicht nichts, um es dauerhaft zu betreiben,
aber zum Testen vielleicht mal gar nicht schlecht.
Moment, irgendjemand hat auf GitHub schon sowas gebaut.
Moment.
Minis Forum Repo?
Was soll das sein?
soll ich irgendwelche random dinge aus dem internet nehmen von mann netzwerk treiber
okay das mache ich installation die bian package halter nick treiber
Source.
Ah, hier ist der Treiber jetzt drin.
Okay.
Trebian.
Ach, hier ist das DKMS-File.
Im Endeffekt ist das alles, was man braucht, oder?
Fake, ohne irgendwelche Sachen.
Also das könnte man tatsächlich
temporär noch benutzen, ja.
Das wird noch funktionieren.
Ja, das könnte man
Mal gucken, ob es dazu irgendwie
einen Google-Eintrag gibt oder so
Dass sich mal irgendeiner beschwert hat
Ähm
Macht der hier DKMS?
Hier gibt es nichts.
Sieht nicht so aus, als ob es da einen Fix gäbe.
Januar 2026.
8, 1, 2, 7.
Hat schon was getan, ne?
Hanks on Suspend Shutdown.
Da hat sich nichts getan seitdem, kann das sein?
Ich glaube, das ist so neu, das hat noch keiner reportet.
Ich glaube, da hat sich wirklich nichts getan in der Zeit.
Na gut, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob sich da nicht doch vielleicht was getan hat.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Die Komets sind unauffällig, finde ich auch.
Ich finde es aber witzig, dass einer schon mal sowas erstellt hat hier.
das ist schon ein bisschen painstamp ganz ehrlich aber das kann also das repo hier kann man kann
man schon benutzen
was ihr autorun punkt es hat
vielleicht brauche ich das auch selbst aber es ist schon hast du ausgeschaltet
Was für ein Ding? Stand das hier eben in den Comments drin oder was?
EEE?
Improve Mac EEE Handling?
Ich brauche R8127.
Okay, Disable EEE.
Was ist denn EEE?
Energy Efficient Ethernet soll ich ausschalten.
das ist intel jetzt gibt es stimmt mit das gibt es schon mit etha tool etha tool
etha tool hier
ok ok gucken wir erst mal
star 2 3 4 7 8 9 bevor wir das jetzt machen ich starte noch mal die vm
und wir finden es noch mal aus
das war auch hier aktuell sind
ssh
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 bäumen moment moment weil es noch plötzlich hier ein paar fisch
mich habe mich schon immer konzentrieren das ist aber auch abfacke lach nick 0
link partner advert e link motz dort reportet aktiv in ebit inactive was er wie jetzt
okay und jetzt
aber das ausschalten
Nick 0
Oh es hängt
Es hängt das ist schon mal schlecht
Das ganze Netzwerk hängt
Pricked
Okay, ist hey, okay, schau
Okay, disabled, okay, okay, okay
Ne, bringt da nix
Ja, Chatge, was für ein Scheiß ist das denn, ey
Es ist aber auch echt verdächtig, ne
Es ist aber auch echt verdächtig
Dass das bei fast der Hälfte
Von 9 Gig hängt, oder?
Da ist doch irgendein
Bug drin
Ich hab noch nie nen Bug reported für den Linux-Körner.
Wenn ich das mache, muss ich das aber wirklich sehr ordentlich machen.
Ich will nicht geflamed werden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ey.
Will nicht geflamed werden dafür.
Wir probieren mal was aus, Chat.
Ich will mal was ausprobieren.
Guck mal hier.
Wir probieren mal die Kernel von dem Dude.
Vor sechs Stunden hat er die Kernel.
Nice.
Geiler Typ.
Without TCP-Recursions.
Der Colonel ist noch heiß, ja?
Ja, vor sechs Stunden.
Let's go
Okay, wie installiert man den?
Achso, ja, gut
Easy
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Es gibt zwei Versionen. Eine, in der Proxmox einige der neuen Sachen zurückgelegt wurde.
In TCP, die Probleme mit der PC-Serie verursachten.
And one of those two are not...
...
Okay.
Dann...
Scheiß drauf, dann mache ich jetzt einfach mal das,
was der Dude hier geschrieben hat.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal das da von dem, ist okay.
Da kann ich nämlich einfach copy-pasten.
Ganz ehrlich, ich will das nicht benutzen.
Das sage ich gleich dabei.
Ich will das nicht benutzen.
Mir geht es eigentlich nur darum, um zu sehen,
ob das dann schneller ist.
Dann warte ich nämlich einfach, bis es
ein neues Kernel-Release gibt. Und gut ist, das dauert
ja nicht ewig.
Okay.
Installieren wir mal unsere Kernel, unsere neue.
Da können wir uns jetzt sonst was
mit einfangen, ne? Mit random
Kernel von GitHub.
Direkt erstmal Rootkit drauf.
Ist der Dude an sich seriös hier? Zeig mal her.
Ja, der sieht schon seriös Hackerman aus.
Da kann eigentlich nichts passieren.
Okay.
Äh.
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Passt alles, oder?
Okay.
also reboot gucken wir mal was der jetzt gleich beim guten sagt ich will einfach nur wissen ist
es jetzt schnell wenn es schnell ist bin ich beruhigt alles okay dann warte ich einfach das
nächste kölner release ab das ist ja kein db jahren das ist ja eine box die haben neuere
kernels als debian dann wird wird box demnächst irgendwie mal neuen kölner
ließen und alles ist gut sollte es nicht schnell sein dann muss ich eventuell
wirklich ein kölner backreport schreiben und mich dann flamen lassen weil ich
irgendwas verkehrt mache
dann auch die melanox karte nehmen mit der man nichts mehr
rockbox start war nicht eingeloggt er hat es gecheckt okay jetzt war erst mal
hier in ein paar nochmals moment was habe habe auf die richtigen karte haben wir
ok ist immer noch genauso schnell schrägstrich langstrich langsam vorher
es ist mit dem neuesten linux karl launen schneller
Das ist irgendein Bug, den auch keiner reportet hat, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das muss ich machen.
Ich habe updremove gesagt.
Chat?
wisst ihr was?
Vielleicht könnten wir da
theoretisch sogar selbst einen Patch
machen, weil
du musst
erst in den alten booten.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt mein System
geprickt.
Ist auch egal.
Ich will es eh nicht verwenden.
Bam, jetzt ist das System kaputt.
können wir vielleicht weil also was mich jetzt noch interessiert ist
hallo
daten please
Ne, da startet noch alles gut.
Weil, jetzt mal so, guck mal.
Wir haben doch hier die History von dem...
Wir können das doch mal diffen.
Guckt mal.
Repos
Haben wir Linux? Git, Clone, Linux
Weil, achso ja
Was wir noch checken müssen ist, ob das hier funktioniert
Weil das ist ja der letzte
Source-Treiber von Realtek
Nicht, dass die in ihrem Treiber, dass die das nur im
Closed-Source-Treiber gefixt haben
Das wäre ja ganz
Pepega
R8127-Source-Code
Was bin ich hier?
Oh, was haben wir hier?
Ah ja ja.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
OpenWRT, okay.
Die machen irgendwas in dem Makefuck.
Vielleicht wurde der Realtek-Treiber auch nur mit anderen Sachen compiled?
aber wo habe ich denn den wo habe ich denn den
realtec 3 aber überhaupt habe ich den hingeschmissen temp kram
er ist also das auskommt drin hast doch guck mal das ist doch das ist doch alles passt doch
weil dann gedownloadet habe ich den kram ich will das einfach mal dürfen will tag
Ja, dann laden wir nochmal runter.
Downward-Files,
jetzt muss ich mir das dumme Captcha lösen.
J-W-S-W-K-U
Submit.
Ist der neue Treiber
überhaupt im Kern leer? Das will ich doch gerade nachgucken.
Also das ist ziemlich sicher.
Okay, wo hat mir jemand was geschickt?
Vom Kernel?
Kernel History?
Ja.
Ah, Moment.
Das haben die alles in diesen Treiber
gemerged?
Oh shit, da kann man nicht einfach
den Source-Code vergleichen.
Ach so.
Ach, die haben quasi nur den Code
mehr oder weniger copy-pasted
in den Kernel-Internal-Kram.
Und haben die Changes wahrscheinlich...
Ach, jetzt check ich das.
Guck mal, die haben...
Das kann ich nicht selbst machen.
Da blick ich nicht durch.
Guck mal, die haben das Ding hier irgendwann mal supportet.
Hier, add support.
Warte mal, wo war es denn hier?
Oder keine Ahnung, wann die den hinzugefügt haben.
Irgendwo haben die angefangen,
den zu supporten.
Irgendwo.
Irgendwo hier, mei. Irgendwie sowas.
So, da haben die angefangen, den zu supporten.
Und
danach kam
nochmal eine neue Version von Realtek selbst.
Das haben die, glaube ich, schnell mitgekriegt.
Ja.
Der Comet ist von Realtek selbst.
Das heißt, Realtek hat einfach ihre Linux-Sachen nicht geupdatet.
Alter, ist das wieder ein Schrott.
Und mit was für einer Scheiße man sich auseinandersetzen muss, man.
Wir werden jetzt noch zum Kernelentwickler, um das zu fixen.
Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer, was hier drin passiert.
Es hält sich aber echt den Grenzen, was da eigentlich passiert.
Ne, das machen wir heute garantiert.
Aber guck mal, das hält sich doch echt den Grenzen, was hier drinne...
...passiert an Updates und so.
ähm, by the way
wo kommt denn das hier her?
ist das hier das eigentliche Ding?
ist das hier das, was der eigentliche, was der Körner irgendwie
ich hab keine Ahnung
ich kenn mich damit nicht aus, man
das ist, das ist über meiner, äh, über meinem IQ-Level
So, wenn ich das hier make,
dann erstellt er was?
Und wo erstellt er was?
Ah, der hat schon installiert.
Ja, der ist ein schlauer Arsch.
Punkt Code, das ist kein Modul.
Wisst ihr was, ich denke, dass das hier irgendwie unter der Haube das da ist.
So, wo müssen wir denn hin?
Wo müssen wir denn hin? Linux Drivers?
Drivers?
Net? Ethernet?
Net? Ethernet? Realtek?
Und das ist alles anscheinend.
Geil.
Top.
Da.
Das Verzeichnis gibt es doch überhaupt nicht.
Das Verzeichnis gibt es doch gar nicht.
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ob das in einer älteren Version auch auftritt?
Sehr gute Idee.
Dann kann ich mir das Diff angucken.
Wir können mal gucken,
ob wir die Firmware austauschen.
Und gucken, ob es das für...
Ja, aber wo? Was? Wie?
Ich habe keine Ahnung wie, wo, was
Also
Da austauschen soll
Also darin
Damit hat es anscheinend schon mal nichts zu tun
Wo kommt dann hier das
Wo kommt dann das überhaupt her
Das ist irgendein Binary
Was die von Realtech gekriegt haben
Kann das sein
Linux Firmware, ja.
Firmware, oder nach was muss ich da suchen?
Ist das ein eigenes Repo?
Okay, ja.
Okay, das haben die als Binary quasi gekriegt von Realtek.
Und Realtek hat das nicht aktualisiert.
Ich glaube, so ist das.
Realtek hat den irgendeinen Binary kompiliert gegeben.
Und...
Nee, das hieß nicht Realtek.
Das hieß RTL oder so, ne?
RTL Nick.
RTL
Ja
Stats, von wann ist das?
Sieht man da irgendwas?
Alter, was ist das für eine komische Ansicht, Alter?
Lock, lock, können wir gucken.
Ja, das ist älter.
Das hat, okay,
dieses ding hat irgendeiner von real tech kompiliert und hat das ding gegeben
die haben das quasi eigentlich nur included bei sich
und wahrscheinlich ist im kernel modul das mit gebundelt
Ist der Treiber oder die Firmware schuld?
Also ich glaube, wenn man das selbst kompiliert, das liegt im Filesystem.
Das heißt, soll ich mal suchen nach dem hier.
Ja, aber das bringt mir ja nichts.
das bringt mir ja nix
da ist es das bringt mir ja nix genau der offizielle treiber hat auch keinen
binary plopp das ist das deswegen glaube ich ja dass diese offizielle treiber
dass sie den genommen haben daraus einen binary gebaut haben und den
Linux Leuten gegeben haben.
Weil im Kernel ist ja offensichtlich
nichts drin.
Ja muss ja, der Treiber, die gibt's hier ja nicht.
Wir haben ja geguckt, wo sie das hinzugefügt haben.
Ich meine, wir können ja mal gucken.
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Ja.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Shit, das ist zu...
Und sonst gibt es da nichts.
Das ist das erste, wo das auftaucht.
Lock.
Ob das jetzt das erste, wo das auftaucht?
Ja.
Alter.
No.
Ja, das ist das erste Comment, wo das auftaucht.
So, und das hatten wir vorhin schon.
Da ist nur dieser Binary-Kram drin.
Sonst nichts, was irgendwie nach Netzwerktreiber großartig aussieht.
Das da.
Hier, das da.
Okay, vielleicht ist das...
Vielleicht ist das der Treiber.
Ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Wobei ich hier nichts sehe von...
Ja, so.
Und irgendwas haben die in der offiziellen...
In dem offiziellen Treiber
haben die halt seitdem gemacht
und nichts den Linux-Leuten zur Verfügung gestellt.
Jetzt weißt du, warum wir Binary nicht mögen.
Ja.
Also, die haben
quasi irgendwas gefixt.
In ihrem...
Der ist zwar auch Open Source,
Realtek-Treiber. Es hat aber den Linux-Leuten
nie jemand Bescheid gesagt,
dass das dort drinnen auch geändert
werden muss.
Lasst Chat-GPT...
Ich glaube, damit ist Chat-GPT
und Claude und was auch immer
maßlos überfordert, weil der gar keine Ahnung hat,
was er genau gucken muss und machen muss.
Ihr könnt ja mal...
Probier die V11-014.
Was meinst du genau?
Du meinst vom Realtek-Treiber das alte?
Also quasi Realtek?
Das habe ich auf Reddit gesehen.
Das Initial Release vom RTL 8127.
Also, du meinst, wir gehen jetzt...
Du meinst das, was bei OpenWrt rumgammelt?
Oder wie, das hier?
Also das da im Endeffekt.
Trixi Backports.
Aha.
Ja, das ist vom 21.10.
Ähm.
Was ist denn da jetzt drin?
Das können wir machen.
Warte mal, das können wir machen.
RTL?
8-1.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, Chat.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Ähm.
Wo kann man sich das runterladen?
Chat, ich bin gerade irgendwie blind.
Wo ist der Knopf zum Downloaden?
Achso.
Ich will das runterladen, entzippen und eine Fünfsumme drüber machen.
Source Package?
Ne.
Ach hier, Architecture All, hier, da ist es doch.
Copy, Link.
Wartet mal, CD, hier, TMP, Wget.
How to extract
Depp.
Kann man das mit
X-Archive aufmachen?
Ich weiß gar nicht. Gibt es eine gescheite? Ich kenne keine
gescheiten GUI
Sachen, GUI-Entpack-Sachen für Linux.
Ich mache nur TA normalerweise.
Das hier, kann das ein Debian-Kram
öffnen? Ah ja, okay, sehr gut.
data user live realtechnik rtl dass da extrakt nach tmp beste effekt sorgt tmp md5 summen
ach da ist es user für mehr
ok 8 fc 554
md5 so packt es ist gleiche 6 sagt das gleiche das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen oder chat
Chat, wir haben bestimmt
eine MD5-Kollision.
Müssen wir nochmal mit Chart
256 machen.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Shit, also das ist schon mal nett.
Okay, also dann Open
OpenWRT
Dann nehmen wir den Treiber hier.
CD, machen wir hier
MKD Repos.
Git, Clone.
RTL, so.
Git, Tags.
Git, Checkout.
Das hier ist das Initial Release, ne?
Ja.
Mehr gibt's da auch nicht drin. Initial Release.
Make.
hoffentlich überschreibt er das jetzt auch richtig tree hat man meint er und co
es gab mal kurz gucken oder auch nicht
ist das ding
chat warum findet er das nicht
Ah hier, User Libmodiums
Okay
MD5 Sum
Okay, und das vergleichen
wir jetzt mal
Find
Das vergleichen wir jetzt mal mit
Repos
Dem da
Das ist ja exakt, wie kann das sein?
Wie kann denn das sein?
Das ist genau das gleiche, hä?
Oh, das ist das gleiche.
Das check ich nicht.
Hab ich denn, ah Moment
Hab ich überhaupt das Richtige ausgecheckt
Ja hab ich, ne
Hab ich
Aber das macht doch gar keinen Sinn
Warum sollte dann das gleiche
Körnelmodul MD5 so mal rauskommen
Chat, wie geht das jetzt nochmal?
Kann ich das jetzt nicht nach X-Arcs
pipen und an MD5
summen? Irgendwie so?
Ja doch.
Ah!
Guck mal!
Ich bin ja auch dumm.
Das sind die Offiziellen, oder?
Nee.
Warte mal, oder doch?
Jetzt check ich's
nicht mehr.
Okay,
das ist...
Ich blick es gerade nicht mehr.
Also,
das, was ich hier liegen habe,
Passt doch, das Modul aus Git und das Modul vom Realtek Download sind gleich.
Ja, aber das hier ist doch das, was ich vorhin Make installt habe, oder?
Hat das Make gerade schon was kopiert?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das Make hat schon was kopiert.
Eben, gerade.
Ich kann irgendwie nicht mehr hochscrollen.
Weißt du? Ja. Ja, dann.
Ach so. Hat das schon was kopiert?
Ach so.
Ach so. Das hat das da schon hin kopiert.
Ich dachte, man muss erst noch
Make-Install machen.
Oh Mann. Das ist ja auch geil.
Okay.
Nee, dann passt das. Jetzt haben wir die
alte Version am Start.
Die alte Version. Jetzt gucken wir, ob die alte Version
auch diesen fehler hat ok also dann muss ich was essen also gehen wir noch mal
hin gut 1 2 3 4 6 7 8 9 modprobe-r wir unloaden den kernel modprobe r8127
da muss man erst mal wieder unloaden auch mal jetzt wieder loaden
ab edf ok sind wir wieder
eth tool ob er hat noch nicht er hat noch nicht gecheckt dass wir wieder da sind
Chat.
Wir sind noch nicht wieder da.
Ist das schlecht?
Großes Problem jetzt?
Äh.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt eher ein Proxmox-Ding.
Ähm.
was hat er vielleicht ein problem aber modprobe minus er
und wir laden das ding gleich wie landes kann noch mal
ok ip link show
läuft die vm glaube nicht
Add if.
Up.
Hä?
Okay.
Okay, jetzt geht das Netzwerk gar nicht mehr.
Nun, das ist in der Tat nicht so geil.
Da können wir das nicht ausprobieren.
Moment, das Ding hat keine IP mehr.
fconfig
1.2.1
2.51
slash 24
äh
vmbr0
Warte mal, ne, mach ich das jetzt falsch?
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
If config zip
Du hast recht, ich hab falsch geguckt.
Das Ding hat ja schon eine IP.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ich hab mich...
Ey, ich mein, ich mach das jetzt schon über 4,5 Stunden.
Kann man doch mal ein bisschen...
Okay, also das Chat, das geht nicht mehr.
Das Netzwerk ist jetzt broken
Allerdings, witzigerweise
Der Link ist immer noch ab
Wir probieren jetzt gerade nochmal was
Wartet mal, ich stöpsel mal kurz
Die Netzwerkkarte rein und raus
Ob das irgendwas macht
Nö
Keine Chance.
Die Bridge geht nicht mehr ab.
Reboot.
Ich muss auch kurz was essen nebenbei.
Aber ich mach auch gleich aus.
Reicht ja.
Gibt es eine Realtek Driver Archive?
Network.
Da.
Okay, gut.
123456789.
jetzt haben wir das eth-tool
minus i was ist das falsche so modpro minus r modpro minus
Add if.
Up.
Oder auch nicht.
Tja.
Chat, der Netzwerktreiber ist komplett kaputt.
Der ging gar nicht bei mir.
Der Initial Release.
Was es für eine Software ist,
das ist KVM.
KVM
Twitch.
Ob man das jetzt richtig nennt.
Also der Treiber
von Shoma Gwarnet.
Wir können jetzt nochmal die
Gegenprobe machen.
Modprobe minus R.
Minus R.
So, wir entfernen das jetzt nochmal.
Wir gehen jetzt nach
root-temp-kram
hier rein
und sagen install,
nee, make.
der fonds kockt der erste ist initial driver release ist brauchen
Okay, guck mal.
Also es hat sich seitdem hier nichts...
Okay, es gab... Leute.
Es gab ganze
Dreikommits, ja?
Das Original Release.
Dann ein paar Monate
später 15.
15 ist auch das, was ich mir von der
Real-Tech-Seite runtergeladen habt. Das kommt vom Datum
her genau hin. Und dann noch mal
Add Read Me.
Da gibt's
nichts mehr dazwischen.
Willst du was
machen?
da hat sich ein bisschen was geändert leute da hat ein bisschen was geändert
so minimal würde ich sagen
hat sich da ein bisschen was schon getan so
Die haben quasi den kompletten treiber umgestrickt
Ah, yes!
Magic!
Magic.
Obviously.
Alles klar, das braucht man.
Classic.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Jetzt weiß ich sofort Bescheid,
wenn ich das lese.
Alles top.
Binary Kram.
Okay, das ist aber schon wirklich hardcore eklig, ne?
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, also
Das wird nicht mit
Mit Kernel 18, 19
Gepfix, weil da ist es nicht drinnen
Mit Kernel 20
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, weil es noch keiner reportet hat
Die wissen ja auch
Gar nicht, was sie machen müssen, ne
Brand mal die KI, ja klar
Natürlich, natürlich
Die wird, okay, okay
ganz ehrlich das muss einer von real tech machen
ja stimmt du hast recht 7 kommt danach hast recht
das muss real tech machen weil bei der anderen das check doch keiner
im box box forum backtracker die erkenntnisse posten
ja da wäre ich vielleicht nicht geflammt wie beim linux karte
Demals hab ich geguckt, da steht nichts großartiges drin.
Außer, dass er angeblich alles korrekt geloadet hat.
Okay, Chat.
Sehr schön, dass ihr alle mit am Start wart heute.
Wem es gefallen hat, kann jetzt ja ein Follow da lassen.
Dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream wieder.
Würde mich sehr freuen.
Grüne Pfeile, die nach oben gehen, sind immer sehr stonks.
Ich gehe jetzt auf S-Wass.
Schalte die Kiste hier mal aus.
Und dann hören wir uns im nächsten Stream.
Genau.
Und Linus direkt taggen.
Please watch stream for more details.
dann werde ich aber auf jeden fall geflammt
erst mal fünf stunden stream
und auch noch auf deutsch
ok chat chat chat wartet mal kurz science technology nee twitch
Twitch Programming. Wir gucken mal, vielleicht kann mir jemand reden heute.
Programming? Nee, das heißt Software. Wie heißt das bei Twitch immer? Software
and Game oder sowas.
Endgame Development
Wie heißt diese komische Kategorie, Alter
Warte mal, kann man bei Twitch
Gibt es bei Twitch nicht
Software und Spielentwicklung, genau
Wen haben wir hier am Start
Sprache, Deutsch
Ist mein Stream eigentlich auch auf Deutsch eingestellt
findet man ja oder
ja sehr schön was ist das denn
sind das sind schweine im stall durch die nacht mit feines aha das würde ich
videos sein wen haben wir denn hier daten ach nee daten
polis plan letzter tag sprint
erkenne ich da habe ich noch gar nichts von gesehen rd game chat
Ich würde gerne immer ein deutschsprachiges
Hosten.
Man hostet jetzt gar kein, Leute.
Ich habe Hunger as fuck.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
War ja so semi-erfolgreicher
Stream, sagen wir mal.
Netzwerkkarte. Die Netzwerkkarte
treibt uns echt um die letzten paar Tage.
Wir hören uns, bis dann, macht's gut
See you
Ups